what up guys welcome to the just perly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the
pregame before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in and guys I have
the most important announcement today
all right you know
all all year you know I I have really
been pushing taking away women's rights
you know there's lots of channels out
there that that push that women should
have more rights and be equal I say
we're not equal the men are better and
we are worse and therefore we should
have our rights taken away so now we
have merch where you can support taking
away women's rights so um the link to
that is in the description so if you
guys want a t-shirt that says women
shouldn't vote make sure you check out
the link in the in the description it's
the audacity network. store that's the
audacity network. store um a couple more
announcements before we start the show
guys if you have a show topic that you
want me to cover um either on Pearl
daily which is my show that I do five
days a week covering you know the news
basically um that's just pearly things
one you can send me um videos to react
to or just videos that we should cover
um and all super chats are going to go
towards a kickout cam now we have a
great we have a great studio um we got
great guests today so we're not going to
use it today but but but you know we do
want to get one so if you donate any
super chats um over how many are we
reading King what dollar amount 20 over
$20 we will read and we'll we'll read
them every like 30 all right let's just
be honest 45ish minutes we'll read super
chats um and King how many likes to open
up the chat today th5 okay 1,500 likes
and we will open up the chat okay so
today we have a lovely panel so guys um
why don't we go around say your name
your age your relationship status and a
fun fact about yourself starting here
and then go around okay so my name is um
Simone uh they call me simma and do I
have to tell you my age yeah yeah why
are you old yeah I'm
21 okay no that's that you're real how
old are you well I'll tell you mine 21
I'll tell you mine I'll tell you it'll
be like I'm 26 so what's I'm the same
age as you I'm 26 I I I feel like it's
not take it all right all right how um
name age relationship status um so my
name is D but I go by the name of de
Chanel I'm also 26 okay and when's your
birthday I'm a Gemini I don't know what
that means oh I'm a I'm June 14th J know
okay I was like maybe we got the same
but we don't I'm a Scorpio oo fiery is
that what that means I think so I don't
know I don't know the
signs okay um fun fact um
I don't really think there's much
anything much fun except for as me the
person do you have any hobbies like
anything nothing no all right what's
your favorite app on your phone oh
Clubhouse really I didn't know anyone
used Clubhouse Clubhouse is quite
popular especially in London it's not
popular where I am but um it's very
popular in London oh and what about
relationship status single single all
right go ahead hey I'm Tony um I go the
name f booy Tony F boy I'm a singer why
a what's the F boy oh it's [__] oh okay
so we can say that can't we yeah you you
can you can yeah we chest so what's is
that like you talk to a lot of ladies at
the same time um yeah which you know
it's it's controversial so it's like it
Blends in with the music and um getting
noticed at the moment which is really
hard to do in London yeah well I'm not
I'm not knocking it I just want to know
so does that mean like your relationship
status is seeing many women uh um yeah
so I like I like people to just think
whatever they want okay that's why it's
just open okay it's just super open okay
so like open relationships that's what
you do I'd say complicated oh okay
complicated so so like situationships
yeah just yeah okay and do you care what
the women do or it's just like open on
they can do whatever they want I would
never tell a woman to do anything oh
never no do what you want okay all right
um fun fun fact you're a musician fun
facts women shouldn't vote you're with
me should we should we drive yeah man
let's I'll drop you off I mean I'll I'll
drop you you need to go let's go that's
what I say I was like if we take away
the driving then they'll drive us around
I probably would as well
yeah um Rel or situationships yeah and
how old are you uh 32 32 okay go ahead
hey um I'm dny um people call me Doc I'm
41 uh I'm married and fun fact about me
is I'm a
magician I wanted him to do a trick but
he said he'd have to stand up I guess I
guess we can't we we'll we'll figure
this out we'll figure we'll figure it
maybe after the show you can you can
yeah all right um so today's topic is
how far will women go for attention now
there was a video that came up I did
cover it on Pearl daily this week that
got me thinking about this and I'm going
to get to that but first um I want to
know what is the furthest you ladies
have gone to get the attention of a
guy what really yeah have you ever like
pursued a guy like really liked him um I
actually prefer a guy to pursue me but
if I have pursued a guy I've actually
gone into a club and approach the guy in
front of my friends okay yeah I mean
that's kind of the Fest I think I've
gone in terms of pursuing a guy okay I
like to be pursued okay have you ever
like um gone somewhere cuz you knew a
guy you liked was going to be there okay
okay okay so we so yeah so that's what
I'm wondering like if when you actually
liked a guy maybe talk to him a bit was
there did you ever like s have you ever
SED really hard for a guy of course
women aren't going to admit that though
I'm going to I have yes yeah I who has
it on yeah exactly it's all right it's
all right we like to play it cool right
we like to ladies like to even though
half the time we' be the ones chasing we
like to be chased you know okay do you
do you think we actually like to be
chased if we always seem to pick the
ones that don't pick us yeah that's the
thing I feel like we always just
naturally go for the ones that are just
hard to get like and we know that
they're players and out of our league
out I don't about that but yeah I mean
if they were in our league they would
like us right and and then you wouldn't
and then you would it like them EXA yeah
exactly it's It's a cruel world it is
terrible s a little rap okay so um but
what what did you do for the guy like
how did you s I mean this was I mean I'm
talking years back I was like I was in a
club this is years back in a club and I
actually ended up marrying the guy
believe it or not oh wow so yeah I was
in the club and um those in those days
it wasn't like it wasn't normal for
girls to really got guys but I was kind
of like drunk and I was like I'm going
for this guy and I grabbed him like like
how a guy grabs a girl and I was like
that is so brave yeah and that was in
front of his friends my friends and you
guys got married got married like years
years later how how how long were you
married are you still married no no
we're divorced how how long were you
together uh 19 years what happened what
happened life what do you mean life life
I don't know I um we were young very
young I never okay I never grew up I
never understand when women like say
this like okay cuz it's like you're
young and then you're old like what what
switched I think when you're young you
have different expectations you you life
different you like different things then
you grow older you go into yourself you
start to know yourself okay um and
sometimes you realize that it's more
headache than what it's worth Okay so
see I still I still don't understand
what this means and it's not just you
I've had so many girls say the same
thing to me on the show and I just
genuinely like like he got into
different
Hobbies you
could cuz I know they're always like we
got into different things be a way of
saying it no you're like we
got I'm like I'm like you got into
different things like what are the
things um like what you don't want to
say are you nervous you know what I want
to say I don't want to say because it's
like yeah you you don't want you don't
want to embarrass I don't want to
embarrass him that's fair you know
you're still he are you a Healer are you
healing I'm Healed you're heal okay what
steps did you take to heal um I think I
kind of just put myself first and just
went for my dreams and done the things
that I should have been doing when I was
younger okay I have I have a question
because this this doesn't compute to me
when it's like I put myself first yeah
how how does that help like build
families cuz isn't it in a family we
should put the family the family first I
mean when I say first I do have two
children so I they always come first
okay so so you put yourself second I no
actually I put myself God first my
children okay and then yeah so um I
think it's in terms of just knowing
myself going into myself knowing what I
like and what I don't like and MH being
confident cuz I wasn't confident when I
was younger okay yes I wasn't really
confident and didn't really know myself
much okay and didn't have a lot of
[Music]
um uh what's the word focus and didn't
have a had ambition but didn't know what
I wanted to do okay you know so I just
thought the way forward is to get
married have kids and that was it and I
was like this can't be just life just
getting married and having kids this
just can't be it it just sounds like you
had it made you were kind I mean I still
have it made I always will it's it's
it's living and learning so it's going
for experiences and learning yourself
learning life and I don't regret nothing
like I don't regret having kids I don't
regret getting married okay so yeah I'll
do it again okay good good glad all
right hardest you've SED for a guy and
did it did it ended marriage she got she
got 19 years out of that that's a lot on
me to be fair can you one up that or no
actually can't now you can kind of guess
my age now
right um um I think the most that I
did it's so embarrassing but it's
actually something I actually need to
speak about so I think the most that I
did was I really liked this guy he was
so sweet I made a private Snapchat for
him shown him the good sides of me cuz
he wowed me like we had a date he really
wowed me like it was so nice and then I
made him a private Snapchat and he
didn't view it or anything so I just end
up self sabotaging the whole thing I
just self-sabotaged the whole thingz I
was just like there's just no point of
me putting myself out there making a
private Snapchat for you and were you
sending him like like like pictures like
that oh yes I was even sending pictures
of me and my cat and everything because
he said he liked my cat so hold on what
theet okay okay so so you made him a
Snapchat to like view your stories but
he didn't watch he didn't watch any of
it and then I kind of just clapped that
basically he was just playing me like it
was kind of sad to be fair okay um so
the hardest you've SED has made made a
Snapchat for a guy okay so we got
approaching him in a club and making a
Snapchat all right now I want to hear
the men what's the hardest you've simped
for a woman um I I made like a whole
plan to get someone back once o yeah I
wrote like a whole note and it was like
week by week um but that's why um I
don't really [__] with women right now
because you lot suck so so what do you
[__] with you lot just suck you lot
Heartbreakers you um why do why do we
why do we suck that's a good question is
it CU we keep
driving or voting I think that's the one
I think you should just stop um I don't
no it's just like the more you give to a
woman um the less they want you so yeah
um I just do the opposite now wow and it
kind of works
okay disagree very disagree you would
say that disagree no you would say that
but why would you don't get to picology
cuz you're you're the woman but why
would you think you're you're you're in
the uh you're in the vehicle why would
you why would you think it's not a good
idea to actually share your share share
share that stuff side you with somebody
because then women automatically think
that you you're too emotional and you're
not a man and that's not attractive to
women it is
it is attractive stop
lying I like I like a
man I like a man that's going to send
flowers you know you get such a ick
that's
you might sub is this is this true or
false women always like the men that
don't like them
back yeah that's kind of true that's
kind of
true but then but then when they find
the I think it's like more of a
challenge like in life you kind of want
challenges right so when you do get the
guy that you like and you've challenged
yourself and you he eventually takes
note of you then it's like you kind of
then want him to soften up so you want
to see right can I push this up a little
bit I will never this is the problem
this is why nothing lasts anymore well I
me I think we're looking for balance you
guys are no balance you guys are both
single so you left every guy you been
with so these emotionally available Guy
where are they
that's true oh they got the I and left
that was it I grew up I I learned I
learned I learned the hard way I mean
when I was when I was younger yeah I
wanted you know a bit of edge but now I
like want selft life baby do you know
what the problem is Instagram and social
medias there's too many options out
there for people I feel like it's a lot
of room to be deceived going on like a
lot of deception is going on especially
when it comes to social media yeah but
you have too many options so you're like
oh don't don't worry if that don't work
out this next one that's why girls get
the so quick but don't you no don't you
have a lot of options me listen I'm just
focusing on me at the moment I can admit
I'm confused you know I mean well most
men don't have a lot of options one out
of three men are either virgins or
having had sex in the past year really
wow yeah I'm going I actually I'm going
to get to you but I kind of want to show
you guys something get to the V
okay okay so we got all right we're
going to get the women here oh my
God here's
the all right so I'm going to show you
guys the
dating so all right so would you guys
agree that you want someone in general
that makes more money than you in
general of course okay would you agree
that you want someone taller than you
yeah absolutely yes okay would you agree
that you want someone smarter than you
yeah in general okay so now the problem
is we all do so here's here's the dating
market so this is going to be the lines
are going to be sex because we're not
getting married anymore so this is just
sex so you know they have sex they have
sex they have sex
I'm gonna add another
chck yeah so this is this is the dating
Market because women date across and up
hierarchies because we want someone
taller stronger so basically we're just
all screwing these guys and ones get
left Beyond yeah and these guys are
virgins so it used to be it used they
might get lucky sometimes they might
they get lucky there they
might one yeah they might pick like this
like this chick might be like all right
right fine but he he'll get her like
once and then she's done she's like I'm
going back I'm going back because women
it's so funny we would rather share um
we would rather be the king's concubine
rather than the peasant's wife
throughout all of time yeah if if a
stronger guy came in and we're like Tri
we're like in a tribe we're all together
and then you know um my bouncer comes in
and kills these guys then boom now we
belong to the bouncer you see what I
mean yeah so the bouncer yeah cuz
basically like if a guy if a guy like
bigger stronger richer whatever came in
you you just you were forced to yeah so
that's why women were kind of Heartless
we just leave after no offense but after
19 years you
know and and yeah so and the other
problem is then can I say something yeah
go ahead go ahead when I was with him he
was down there oh okay how how tall was
he he's not that much taller than me I'm
quite taller than 5' eight so he was
about six foot okay so that's top 15% of
men
okay okay how much how much money did he
make I mean we were in teenagers so
nothing no now like after the 19 years
like roughly after the 19 I mean
he he made the most money in between I
think I think he I think I make more
money than him now okay okay well that's
usually when women leave so thank you
for I had a suspicion okay so so um how
how much money did he make roughly when
which B when you were together just give
me a rough so we started from started
from the bottom now here no he still
start no he still started here if he was
top 15% of height okay at least so then
how much money did he
make what in between in the middle oh my
God just just you know just say 20 to 25
a year I mean normal wage I think okay
25 25 Grand a year noral okay so a
normal so okay but he was still above
average in height yeah um he was musly
and okay so he was hot he was a hotti
all right so we still up here now we get
to the root now we get to the root of
this yeah and so U maybe going to be
watching this thinking why is she no but
this is this is what the women like this
is what we do we usually go for the hot
guys when we're younger and then later
we're like a [__] I want to like have a
better lifestyle so I'm either going to
make money myself and leave or I'm gonna
I'm G to find a guy that's richer these
are Trends it's not every chick what
about you want to find yourself spent so
many years with a man go by yourself so
this is the problem I'll tell you I'll
tell you finding my this is what I found
so here is Instagram okay that Ru things
a little bit as well so here's Instagram
so the problem with Instagram is they
make all these chicks over here think
they're hotter than they are trust me so
they think so we we have this thing
where we just like believe Instagram so
I've seen the trend of finding yourself
it's like these chicks do these Tik toks
like leaving their boyfriends and like
moving to a new country or something
yeah I've seen this and and yeah
Instagram is like yes the streets are
super fun and so the women that are
married here right and they maybe maybe
she snagged this might you know maybe
she snagged this guy or this guy she was
like all right I can't these guys keep
pumping and dumping so I got to stop
here and and so now they get married
here right but Instagram comes in and
basically and convinces her that she can
get this guy now or this guy or maybe
she starts to make more money then
usually think she can do better or just
make enough money to live without him um
and so basically when women don't need
Men We tend to leave them for whatever
reason we just tend to go yep leave them
for more money is that awful or is that
this I would say it's our fault for
leaving yeah but do you know what yeah
old school relationships used to
actually work on their issues and their
problems
andun stuck out this is why we shouldn't
vote what if the man stops leading a
woman so what happens then if he stops
leading a woman which a man is typically
supposed to do well did you did you stop
following why is it always if you stop
leading I'm GNA stop well well I I think
you know I I think that's kind of an
excuse because I think when you think of
the most docile feminine women I'm not
saying it's me but I'm saying like when
we think of like the most docile women
they're going to be led even if a guy
isn't like the strongest lead how guys
naturally lead that's part of who they
but what if they naturally stop leading
okay what does that mean stop leading
like if stop being a man okay what does
that mean just fall back and just this
is what I find I find that usually okay
it'll start start man because God are
above the men and then the women this is
just my beliefs okay so you know take
this or leave it but I think usually
when I hear that it means she's a really
argumentative domineering woman that um
you know basically made his life hell
for 20 years and he just got tired of
like listening to her [__] so he just
I'm not saying it to you I don't of this
is just this is just what I find because
like usually a guy will tell you
something and do you listen or do you
accuse him of not leading you know this
is it depends what he says well see that
means you can't follow what he does see
but it shouldn't depend this shouldn't
depend when you when you tell your kids
something do you say do they say it
depends when I'm going to listen no no
they they're just supposed to listen cuz
they're below they're he oh so you're
saying the woman is below the man so she
should just listen anything what he says
if he says um you know just jump off a
cliff well I think if he tells you I
think you know I think there are some
extremes like I'll give you an example
when I'll give you an example where I
would listen I'll give you an example
when I I don't believe in birth control
so I wouldn't if a guy told me go on
birth control I'd be like look I think
that's against that's true
against so so you know but that's it the
pull out method what do you mean what
are you looking you not know what to
pull out I think when you get married
you should just yeah all right not pull
yeah I think you just you know see what
happens but um but yeah so that's what I
think I think usually when relationships
end it's the woman's fault yes really do
you know what no no I don't agree so
what if it's a situ what if it's a
situation as you said the man the man
not being the leader anymore why if he
just lacks motivation if he likes
teaching you better or bettering okay so
how okay tell me like what motivation is
give me an example um for example okay
cool um I'm like oh babe I want to set
up a cake shop um just you know to
better us you can manage it but um I
want you to set like help set up a cake
shop he's probably not going to motivate
you or push you in the direction of you
can simply getting the stuff of you know
the cake Cutters or tools that you would
need I'll give you I'll give you an
example this cake shop you know men are
more logical so most men would probably
say that's a stupid idea they yeah and
that's the thing cuz women we're LED
with our emotions what's like fun in the
moment right you know but men are just a
little more logical so I think a lot of
times we have stupid ideas and we bring
them to men and they kind of like nicely
tell us no but we don't take a hint but
but you guys can tell me if I'm wrong
but no but the other side of this is
like it's his investment like he's
investing into this into into your idea
for a cake shop for a cake shop okay but
maybe did okay did he say yes to the
Cake Shop I asked him I wanted him to
motivate me okay why is it his job to
motivate you he's the leader not the
motivator
[Laughter]
like well it's like he to motivate your
children and your woman not really okay
so is so good why can't you motivate
yourself I don't no cuz now now you're
all a strong independent woman and
you're finding
your independent woman you want you want
to be behind
you no let's fix it you're behind him
he's in front yeah he's the leader yeah
he's the leader but if he's not leading
you or the children do you do if he's
out okay if he's out spending five days
a week in the club okay and he's
drinking and he's whatever and he's
partying and you don't see him at night
you don't he doesn't see the children
what do you do then is he leading still
okay okay so then I would ask why are
you with a guy that spends five days a
week in the club and that's why a woman
leaves no no no no this is what no no no
this is what chicks do this is what
chicks do you pick a guy that showed you
who he was and then we whine about it
later so I say okay you you picked a
clubber so stay with them that was what
you picked but why deception why
decep who's more deceptive men or
women that's not the point okay then
then it could be both ways I'm not going
to why do we have make fake hair you
know fake bbls men can fake their
hairlines nowadays have you seen okay
okay who fakes their hair more men or
women women but who who has who has B
more mental more lies what yeah mental
more generally just lie about everything
yeah but women are more deceptive if
their lies who who lies more men or
women men I'm sorry oh no oh no yes
women are so
deceptive you f
yeah if if you're not going to lie
you're not going to lie hard who cheats
better men or women women okay there we
go that's true
that's women do cheat better that's the
truth yeah yeah but so yeah this is the
dating Market though yeah and these are
usually so the the problem we get into
is throughout our 20s we'll just either
sleep with sometimes marry one of these
two guys but then we get to our 30s and
40s and say I want something more long
term and then they're like I'm gonna
pick these guys but then they're like oh
no now I have a ran through wife I'm
sad and that's that's that's how I have
this channel you know I mean thank you
thank can I get some Round of Applause
oh that was amazing I love the
demonstration I just like to be
appreciated um okay
so simp have you ever simp um you've
been married have you been married for a
minute yeah 15 years we been married 10
years oh wow so it's a little different
now in the dating game right yeah yeah
yeah very was dating apps around then
nope Instagram was it big Facebook no
nothing it's that's like a whole
different world right yeah we actually
meet people yeah no you know that's the
number one way people are meeting under
30 I'm going to give you guys some stats
the number one way people are meeting
under 30 is online and and women only
swipe right on dating apps 5% of the
time really so yes so we're really only
screwing that top guy he's like he's
really just he's doing well he's doing
very well I think I'm like the second
guy cuz I ain't got a lot of H I'm I'm
average so okay so you're
the the second guy almost there
yeah yeah so so how how did you meet
your wife
then um I used to dance in a club where
she worked so I used to be a break
dancer um she worked beond the bar and
one that to another okay and what made
your wife like wife
material she was just she's just
different she was amazing she was cool
she was just like a female me oh really
you guys are really similar yeah can she
do magic tricks too no that's where we
did you got a teacher yeah got to keep
some secrets and what do you what do you
see that's like different um do you have
any friends that are dating
now are they all married no give be so
dating okay and what do you like what do
you see that's different now from
before it is a lot of Technology it's
very
and I
think people are quick to end things and
not give things a go like perh we used
to back then you sort of like have a
date that that don't work go next one
because it's more readily available it's
easier yeah actually I have a question
have you guys ever been in a virtual
relationship sorry what's that like a
distance like a sorry know sorry long
long distance sorry yeah on the long
distance relationship okay how how long
did you do it for currently doing it
okay how long how long have you been um
couple of years now two years so two
years and how often do you see him
um a few times a year lately okay what
is what does he do he I tell you is that
everything he does I don't know if he
wants me to say well would we know who
he was based on his
occupation um he does a couple of things
yeah he went to security and and yeah
okay so you see him like what five times
a year no not that much we've only been
together for yeah just under two years
and is this your first like distance
relationship it is okay what about you
um so we partly was together for like a
year when he lived in my city and then
um he moved back home so we'll like see
each probably like probably once or
twice a month okay yeah so I found that
the distance thing I don't I don't know
about you guys but is a way for the top
men to just have multiple girls in every
city yeah yeah you know so anyways have
you done the you the secrets yeah well
well no I'm just I'm trying to explain
how even more it's like expanded the the
top guys just so that is that what you
do Mr [__] boy I don't do anything do
your friends do that is that why are you
winking what's the I want him I want the
secret I got a nervous twitch um I don't
I don't think it was guys he's he's
joshing me I don't like it's like um
what my longest was like a a month
between that was it once a month that
was the longest yeah it's like that for
me maybe just want some up yeah so I
have a couple super chats um I'm going
to read these they're big ones F Matra
an immigrant picking fruit in Florida
gets respect from his wife culture
matters th Matra says n BS most women
are incapable of self reflection and
accountability you pick a man and we're
not clubbed over the head you had
choices the honest a-hole says a leader
has to have direction to lead if he's
not motivated to move into a specific
Direction then he isn't leading true me
refresh it and just double check there's
no more it's just a couple but thank you
it's $100 Super Chat so we're gonna
we're going to clap for that one all
right
um okay so the reason that I thought of
today's topic which is what is women
what will women do for attention is
because um recently there's an Instagram
model who um well actually what
originally made me think of this topic
was I was in Vegas and in Vegas they
actually made it legal to put nipples on
your or like um stickers on your boobs
on your nipples so they would walk
around like they're literally topless
it's legal in Vegas and I was thinking
about how it's like when women get the
chance to like just get naked we just
love to I don't know what it is I was
just like wow is that an LA thing or no
no I mean I even if I go to shortage at
night it's like I see chicks half half
naked you know what I mean and so I was
thinking about how a hundred years ago
if you watch like videos of women
walking down the street they're all like
covered from head to Cho but we had less
rights then you know but it was like
when we got rights I was like we just
really love being horse it's just super
crazy and I found out the stat that one
out of 25 women are on only fans under
the age of 35 and it's becoming a bigger
percentage of the workforce than
teachers that's horrible I know I know I
was like wow we just can't it's a lot of
attention correct and so I was thinking
about how um and I was also thinking
about how modern-day women are the
equivalent of porn addicts because um
we're so addicted I I think um attention
is to women is sex is to men yeah
because if you ask women you know um
could you have eternal youth Mo like
there's a reason you wouldn't say your
age right I think most women we want to
stay like 21 forever yeah correct it's
Forever 21 not 31 right and so I was
thinking about how women when given the
choice like we were always going to pick
attention from men and we would pick it
over sex like if you could have sex with
whoever you wanted or you could stay
looking 21 forever most women would pick
looking 21 forever most generally where
men would pick sex with the supermodel
wow right right right so that's I was
like I think it's the equivalent and I
was thinking about how it's like we have
wives and mothers that are like so
addicted to attention that like we have
these like thirst traps on Instagram and
you can't even really tell the
difference now between like wives and
mothers and like single CH you know like
it used to be when you were younger you
might dress you have a little leg and
then like you get married and put it
away now it's it's crazy and I was yeah
so yeah so this went so far that this
chick was an only fans model and
actually died for attention so pull pull
the video
King died yeah I'm I'll show
you oh
my that is
treacherous
[Music]
what happened next oh did we not get the
they might have cut
it no so so she hit a
pole so she hit a she hit a pole and
then died and she had she had a daughter
wow wow and and it's like it's it's sad
because it it's almost like why do you
think we have a society that people are
going to such extreme lengths to get
attention as opposed to 100 years ago
where it really wasn't the same well I
enjoyed the video up until she died rest
in peace her yeah I feel like you know
because like you know because like
there's a lot of things that happened
where you know people were looking for
jobs with what happened many years ago
and um you know only fans kind of helped
out a lot of people I feel like maybe in
her circumstances she probably felt like
only fans helped her such as with um her
income and so such however like I think
Where She Went Wrong is as a mom like
she should have done better for her
child by getting an actual regular job
rather than actually doing so much for
money instead of actually valuing that
she has a family and eventually like the
bigger picture is fair enough she died
but her child is her child and her child
friend is going to be able to go online
and actually look at her mom's naked
body like do you think it's selfish when
women do that of course because why
would you want to shame yourself
you know as woman we're kind of like the
bottom of the barrel realistically as
you would refer to but why would you
want to shame yourself by putting
yourself like online naked I think it's
only shameful cuz Society standards but
then wouldn't you rather instead of
putting it on a place where you can you
know pay to go and see somebody naked
and or do something with whatever they
do would you rather just go on porn
where it's just free I don't know so
you're saying like free and selling it
is different yeah you mean it's society
that tells us it's shameful yeah like I
I don't I just natural in it you think
it's okay being naked but would you wife
a girl like that though why not I don't
judge anyone okay each to their own
that's it like everyone says everyone's
all right hold on you don't get me no no
I don't believe you get that's a good
that's a good way of putting it I don't
believe you either you don't get me no I
really don't do you do you do you
consider yourself to be a more
traditional guy no yeah see but that
that's it because you're more modern
like do you I'm just are you looking to
get married right now I'm so heartbroken
and numb females this is why it's like
you're um you're you you started the
show with [__] boy like of course the
[__]
boy yeah but it's like of course you're
going to say that I just I don't judge
people anymore but I think cuz I don't
want to be judged I feel like it's I
think I think we no I think we need to
increase the Judgment okay yeah I think
we need to be more more judged because I
think when we stop judging women respond
really well to social shame so you know
we want to be a part of the group and
it's like why do we respond so quickly
to fashion trends like everyone's going
to be buying my shirts now you know
because I started this but but you know
what I mean like we'll wear the
stupidest outfits right you you'll see
holes in our jeans holes in our shirts
and they're like why are you wearing
that because we respond really well to
Trends and social shame C and so right
but why do we think it's cute because
someone else said that I mean you know
you can't you can't lie the extent of
the holes in now is kind of crazy but
before you know the little slits in the
jeans like you bought one you know you
bought one no I'm not even saying I'm
above it I'm still a woman but I'm
saying like I'm not saying I'm better
than anyone I'm just I'm describing the
trend so I think when we have a society
that doesn't have shame I think
ultimately the people that pay the price
are the children yeah and and I think
like that's the most important thing is
you should protect kids yeah and so it's
like when you have a mom that's like
slept with the entire town you know and
now they're going to go to school and
get bullied now your mom's a [__] yeah
that's true yep you disagree no I agree
oh so you switched your opinion now no
no it's not it's not switch it's just
like everyone could do whatever they
want but I don't think that there's
going to be a big enough movement to
change things yeah so you've accepted
you've accepted or you just get
depressed about it I just think cuz it's
so generalized as well going to get
worse it's just going to get worse it's
a bit nihilistic approach an approach
for me but well I think at some point
menal kind of
I think at some point men will take
power back from women just have too much
power I think social media is just going
to get worse and worse yeah more there's
nothing worse than what's going on right
now none of you can lie there's nothing
worse than what's going on right now
like you are right we should really and
truly protect the kids because at the
end of the day like everyone in this
room we are Road models to a child
regardless but it's there's nothing
worse than why it is right now like you
can't do anything worse than what's
going on yeah but how how can we change
it I have a couple things I got I got I
got some solutions for you so um I say
one we got to get rid of no fault
divorce once you get married you're
stuck for Life yeah yes I think that's
number one depends I think no I think
I'll give you an out I'll give you one
out I'll give you an out for abuse if
he's Bea in your
ass but but none of this like money like
money abuse people like certain people
would just say oh this is happening oh I
know that's the women lie all the time
about it so so but what I would do is
one um I would I would make it so if she
falsely accuses you she goes to jail and
it would be really har so what about
emotional abuse cuz you phys emotional
abuse no I don't believe in that oh God
I think I think emotional
abuse no I think I think women
emotionally abuse men I don't think men
emotionally don't believe in
manipulation I think I think all of
these are just words that women make up
to make themselves victims so when and
that's why what if you woke up every
morning and your husband looked at you
and said you look disgusting well then
i' say do with you I'd say how can I
improve and then what if he says you
can't right what you do then well then
I'd say i' say I think I think that
sometimes we just want to make ourselves
Vic like what is that going to
do so would you kind of say like all
right then cool except for abuse like
let's just put abuse in another category
cuz that's separate so would you say
like for example the woman has to like
be already like acceptable like make
herself acceptable for the man such as
issu was fat you know fats falling out
everywhere like a bag of potatoes yeah I
think she have to hit the gym or
possibly even get surgery to die in the
table like would you say that's the
extent a woman will have to go to to to
get surgery okay I think I think that we
should start with the treadmill I think
that's but yeah I think if he
salad self improvement but but the wife
is cooking steak and macaroni and cheese
for her man so she's never really going
to yeah but she can eat the salad though
mean all for self but that's still but
that's still the woman lowering herself
meet the man's ex self-improvement is a
must man or woman self- Improvement is a
must but there but there's emotional
abuse where someone's making you feel
like you don't want to live then you're
going to stay with that person there a
whole wild world nobody I just think
nobody can make me feel anything I think
women got to stop I think no I think I
think women I know cuz women are
addicted to being victims look at every
movie on TV creatures every I agree with
you I agree with you but like we just
have a society that never tells us the
truth and like we look in every TV show
every Taylor Swift song it's you are a
victim poor you like at some point
Taylor Swift I want an album it was me I
am the problem but that's where that's
where lead that's where well like was
saying earlier leadership comes back in
because if you have a strong man in the
house that's that's um representing
leadership and he's putting installing
strength and installing yeah but he's
going to tell you the truth and you're
still not going to like it no no no
she'll say she was emotionally abused
yeah but there's a truth and then
there's just someone just blatantly
taking the piss and just knowing that
you're not strong to you it all stems
from the beginning though like everyone
has to pick their pie of [__] and I
think work with it and you have to work
with it because real realistically
realistically in a way you know a piece
of [__] and a piece of [__] together is
big pile of [__] so so let's just live
in a b well why is it always assumed
that he's the piece of [__] maybe you're
the piece of [__] I mean no one's
perfect realistically there's some
traits that you yourself are going to
have to water down to match the piece of
[__] yeah so well I look every
everyone's got problems right so
but so so I just think I think that a
lot of times women want to like say oh
the man didn't lead but usually this is
just what I find I really think men
naturally do lead when they have women
that follow that don't give them help
then but that's the thing not every man
I mean it's nice to find the ones that
do lead but there's a lot of men that
don't know how to lead and that's due to
like maybe they're up why don't you
would you give them the opportunity I
have a question but who raised those men
right that's what I'm saying sometimes
they don't sometimes men yeah right but
sometimes they're not raised correctly
or raised in a two parent home where you
need a man and a woman that's the
problem because women keep leaving and
they have no respect for you got men
that don't respect women in the first
place because the way they were raed why
why would they when their mom left right
that's what I mean so it all goes back
down to the leadership once you've got
good leadership it goes back to the
women's choices yeah and no no I feel
like there's a lot of aspects to why I I
feel personally I feel like for men who
can't lead a woman or even his family I
feel like there's a lot of like
background issues that go into that
however where I have to where I have to
actually step into this and be like you
have to you have to also be strong for
the man you have to also be there for
the man if your man is weak which you as
a married person if you feel like you're
weak in certain aspects for example
you're sick your woman's going to look
after you if you feel like you know you
not met my wife oh she leaves me do it
fair enough but in certain circumstances
like if you if if you feel like you're
weak in a relationship that person
should be able to nurture you and you
should be able to do the same thing for
the other person a lot of women don't
submit nowadays and that's that's the
truth there's a lot of women especially
this generation everything that's going
on with social media like you said a lot
of women do not know how to submit they
expect you toit expect I think I
definitely do now I think when I was 16
17 I don't think I knew have to submit
but now um that's what I want to so he
tells you he tells you delete your
Instagram are you doing it yeah
absolutely doesn't mean that much to me
okay I mean I I like I love my Instagram
and I you know that's where I Network
and do my music and stuff but if I was
with somebody that I felt that secure
with and happy with and we're building a
life together and I ask him to do
something he doesn't mind why not well I
think I think the issue that that I get
into or I see a lot as women think we
submit but it's really conditional
submission because it's only when he's
leading perfectly no but no one's
perfect yeah but that's but like when
you're saying earlier oh he stopped
leading you know it's like is he only
supposed to love you when you're perfect
I it's not even just about love it's
about it's about there's a lot of things
there's a lot of aspects into having a
relationship and it's about trust if
you're waking up happy if you're waking
up unhappy every day then I don't see
why you should hear me out I think
you're happy happiness doesn't matter of
course it matters no I don't think it
matters at all I think we've told us
women yeah I know I know shocking he me
both
men I'll tell you so so I think we live
in a society that's very self-centered
and everything's about us and I think
especially women um we've gotten a ton
of attention from the time we were like
14 15 years old when we got on social
media you know um or whenever right
because we got Facebook we got and so
you're immediately given all this
attention from men right and I think
this has kind of made us brainwashed to
think we're more important than we are
we're more special than we are and I
think we think our opinion matters more
than it does I'm not saying our opinion
doesn't matter at all but I I don't
think I think couples that really made
it 50 60 years they weren't concerned
about happiness I think they were
concerned about Duty and playing your
role but now we've been told it's about
me me me and my happiness and I think
that should be last especially when you
got kids I feel like that is due now
because if you look at it social media
has given so many people a voice I feel
like social media is definitely a bigger
part to paying it and I also have to
blame Disney because Cinderella Snow
White we all know we all know how it's
gone it's been pushing our faces to have
that fairy tale but I feel like where we
where we go wrong is realistically
everyone deserves happiness why would
you want to be in a situation where it's
a [__] show of like there's I think a
lot of times women don't even know makes
us happy and no no seriously because
because we we think we think very short
term so we'll go for that top guy right
and is getting pumped and dumped a
couple you know by the top guys really
going to make us happy like think about
it the last hundred years we've had more
Choice than ever we could do anything we
want and we have chosen to be [__] as
a group 100 years ago 85% of us were
virgins on our wedding days think about
that a hundred years ago even even let's
just say the women were Liars right
let's double the amount like let's make
it from 15 to% that's still two out of
three that waited till they were married
got married young stayed married and so
it's like what what has us choosing done
for us for our happiness when we follow
our hearts it's like we're led to
destruction but then you have to
remember why women were a were were so
much like you have to remember why women
so much had to like fight for their
rights in certain in certain situations
not every situation in certain
situations no I'll tell you it's all
propaganda they like funded the schools
and like the women's studies department
and basically rewrite history and
there's like his there's like articles
of them doing this they basically say
we're going to speak for the women at
the time but the women of the time can't
speak for themselves so for example the
anti- um
the suffragettes which is the women that
were like fighting to vote um really
weren't popular they weren't liked
people thought they were crazy and they
even wrote at the time I don't think we
like it's going to be tough for us to
convince women to get out of the home
and anti and they planned bombings they
planned assassinations like these women
that are like painted as Heroes like
fighting for our rights they really
weren't they weren't the people you
think if you actually read like The
writings at the time the anti-s
suffragettes was like a bigger movement
than the
suffragettes so but yeah it's it's
that's but see the reason you think that
is because of the propaganda it's like
they put like women were just so easy to
influence
it it's so and everyone's catering to us
so the the companies are trying to sell
us something all the time so typically
what the companies will do is sell us
that we can be young forever that's like
that's like what they'll typically
because women are the biggest Market
realistically because we
consume yeah and like the education they
like sell they they sell us a lot of um
Majors that just make us victims or we
can like psycho analyze men like we love
psychology and like Psychiatry and like
women's
study
an education you know no this is my I
don't know I don't know what it is um
and then on top of that the the
politicians are all catering to us too
and the men are trying to sleep with us
so they don't really tell us the truth
either like he's saying he's going to
wife a hoe no offense
but I love her yeah for the night but if
you looking for a wife tomorrow you're
probably not going you're not even going
to look at those or if you had the
choice you'd pick a chick that was more
pure for a wife
yeah exactly but like what the I don't
discriminate sorry but okay if you were
going to have a child with someone you
wouldn't I would I would choose the best
of the bunch yeah 100% I agree with you
me personally what what would you be
happy to bring home to show Mom to show
mom or your grandma or like someone
dearest to you like someone that ticks
all the boxes at Society deemed great
good right okay yeah so what like what
oh someone that's just got um someone
that's like family orientated a homebody
someone that goes to the gyms into
fitness but also a hoe but also a hoe
you can get all of those things she's
still she can still be ho no no no no no
you said who would I like to bring home
okay yeah I'd like to bring home someone
with the the attributes that s would do
you mind so if she had all those things
but you knew she'd kind of been around a
little bit or whatever would you just
forget all of that and say this is a
good woman um we just jail depends on if
she's been with my friends or not okay
she hasn't been with your friends yeah
we can forget see I like that's that
that's what I like because a lot of men
will be childish and be like oh I could
never be with her because she did this
in her past and she did that in her par
as they should oh that's actually one of
my Solutions is I think men should only
get married to virgins oh wow
you no no hear me out hear me out okay
let me let me Pitch this to you that's
the next t-shirt
let me P it let me PCH it to you let me
Pitch it to you now you know I I'd like
to say as you know a a non virgin you
know what I me I'm
26 this wouldn't even benefit me but I
really think it would benefits Society
okay virgins have a 70 to 80% chance of
a happy marriage now what happens when
the marriages break down what happens um
there's more criminals there's more PE
there's more kids that run away from
home yeah yeah most criminals are from
single mother homes there's most people
in mental institutions single mother
homes School shooters single every like
problem the homeless single mother homes
it's really and single father homes
don't have the same effect okay so
so when a woman has zero Partners she
has 70 to 80% chance of being happy
after 10 years if you've slept with five
men which the consensus from the men is
most women have slept with five men you
know the women will fight me tooth and
nail on this but when I talk to the men
they're like yeah all these chicks it's
at least five like they're like five is
like a virgin now that's what they you
know that's what the guys are tell would
you guys agree or disagree okay they're
like they're like four that's amazing
like and so um when you get to five it
goes down to a 20 to 30% chance of being
happy so now he's entering a contract
where the woman can take everything she
can take your kids she can take your
house and she could take half of your
money pretty much at any time and she
could falsely accuse you of abuse and
then go to court like it's really the
odds are really stacked against them in
court and so this is really risky right
he could work his whole life just to
have his wife take his [__] and then his
kids are going to be messed up too so I
just as a guy like I think that he they
should just not make children with non
vergins and just throw all the non
virgins away until the next generation
of women are like I want to get married
and it seems like that's the only way to
get married and I think we would learn
you know and then maybe a couple a
couple non virgins will like make it
through do you know what I mean like a
couple non virgins will be like all
right I'm going to work really hard and
just worship the ground he walks on and
then they might get in you know what I
mean but like I think women we just
don't appreciate men unless we have to
work for them and I think the problem is
now we just get them for doing nothing
and I think the men should like raise
their standards and I think that would
fix a lot not everything but I think
that's step one so take away our vote
get rid of no fault divorce and only
Mary virgins yeah you're welcome then
there's going to be a lot of single
women out there no I do think men should
raise their standards though Ely there's
going to be a lot of single women out
there and more or less based on our own
choices yeah but as well there's going
to be a lot of us running to the span
Banks and that's going to also develop a
lot of sing Oh I think that um women
should be banned from sperm banks yeah
yeah I think um I think yeah this is
another thing I think we we can go if we
have like okay if you have fertility
issues with a husband that makes but if
you're not married like why are you
choosing single motherhood that's just
selfish you should be banned so all
these single wom that want to run to the
sperm bakes instead of dating an average
guy the one at the bottom yeah yeah yeah
it's like the one at the Bottom's
waiting for he's waiting to I just think
I think wom really nice guy he's a nice
guy a nice yeah I just think um we have
to options and I just think Society will
be better if we had some consequence I
think at least the top two guy like if
if Brad Pit said I want a virgin
tomorrow he could get one like and so if
you told like they have to make one you
know like obviously a guy at the well
what they have to make one in a lab
somewhere all the women start that way
he just have to wait like five years for
the next round to 22y Old yeah so I I
agree with you I think but like these
women you know made the bed lieing it
and you know I think if you don't want
that outcome learn what men want work
really hard and some you'll get someone
but I think the majority got to wait for
the virgins you know what what what do
you think cuz this must be so crazy to
you like as someone who's married what
do you think
um I was I was cool with it she
um I'm not I'm not not necessarily need
a virgin
okay it' be a perk though right it'd be
like yeah yeah I mean if it got crazy
high body count then yeah I'm not I'm
not down for that but you're like a
little freak in the bed yeah but what if
she was like super hot though you got to
learn something somewhere what if she
was like super hot though no and she was
your type and you look got on really
well no still no just cuz of the body
yeah okay well what's he going to do
with like the the kids the kids yeah
like you want a [__] raising the kids
well maybe she changes her ways halfway
through a housewife yeah do do women
possible though I like challenge okay do
do do women uh typically change for the
better yes they say they do I don't know
I mean it's hard it's hard for a leopard
to change his spots I just think s
improves more or women men men like
women whenever I hear this like healing
stuff it's like nothing yeah no offense
it's like I focus on like our like men's
self-improvements like I went to the gym
I made more money women's like I focused
on
myself self-improvement I went to the
gym I made more money yeah but it's like
it's like by focusing on yourself you
become a worse like partner for someone
yeah I think so yeah Rel some you
attract what you are and that's what I
believe you attract what you are so if
you if you focus on God you focus on
your home you focus on your money you
focus on your body you focus on your
spirit your mind you're going to attract
someone that focus on the same do
selfish women typically make good
wives um no because you have to be an
unselfish person to be so what do you
think would benefit what do you think to
be a wife would benefit us more to focus
on ourself or focus on others um to
focus on others but I mean you have to
have that time where you know yourself
because if you don't know yourself you
can be actually very lost inside the
household I'll be so I'll be so honest
with you as someone who has been single
for a while I would definitely say it's
not about focusing on yourself I feel
like it would be more like appreciative
and learning more from the people around
you such as like friends and family like
you you can you can actually like
without being in a relationship you can
actually give them more time as well to
kind of learn more and also hitting the
gym you know leveling up having you know
more qualifications on you about
bettering yourself
me that's I mean like when I mean like
better yourself when you are you know
fulfilled within yourself you attract
better that's what I find anyway you
attract more you want more um you love
more so I think when you love more you
get more love back so but then it
depends because if you're someone who is
going to like be single and stay at home
or you know as pal said be more selfish
single life is no it's not nice like
everyone knows it's not nice likeone but
obviously you're going to have so much
focus on yourself when somebody comes in
you know you're never going to really
see what's good for you in that
situation you're never going to really
see how much that person just wants you
as a person or come into your life and
actually do something for you yeah
that's I I mean I totally agree I think
you always need to keep learning more
you always need to surround yourself
with good people I couldn't imagine my
life without you know having a family um
without having my kids I could never
they go away for like a day or two and
I'm I'm going crazy cuz I'm not used to
that so definitely a family home is a
must for me personally you look sound
like an Instagram
motivation don't push it I might just
make
one all right them quotes I'm going to
read we got another $100 Super Chat
thank you okay than Matra he's back um
he says when men have the most options
and resources between 27 to 43 they
marry when women have the most options
like Youth and fertility they opt for
the outside enough said um D cellus um
Pearl I love your shirt cool dating hat
now the hack now the women will come to
me yes guys if you just want to be a
ladies man you want the women to just
come up to you and talk to you all the
time these shirts it's in okay I don't
have them in white I just have them in
black but they're in um they're in the
description it's um The Audacity
network. store that's the audacity
network. store get you a woman shouldn't
vote shirt we have gotten too many
rights we've gotten out of control we
need to take them away we need to start
repealing our rights driving is next I
think we'll do women shouldn't drive
next now um creation Muse it all starts
in high school the guys have no real
money but are popular or attractive it's
not that women are dating the same guy
it's the fact that they are dating the
same types of guys the honest a-hole a
leader has to have the oh I read that
one already um Prager it was alleged
that Lucy lety killed the baby for her
doctor's boyfriend's attention for her
doctor boyfriend's attention enough oh
my god oh yeah that's I'm I'm GNA yeah
we're going to talk about that nstep um
RTV the truth is that biologically women
are only loyal to their feelings where
men are loyal to responsibility so
that's why they can cheat or leave so
easily yeah what do you guys think that
Lucy let be um was killing literally
killing children for attention
I think that's disgusting like it's
something that the bigger picture is
like it's something that should never
have been swept underneath the rug like
fair enough doctors do kill people by
accident sometimes by giving them wrong
medication or you know diagnosing them
or something but realistically like why
would you not want to take somebody
else's health so much more seriously and
sweep that underneath the rug SE Seven's
just too much how did that's I was going
to say how did that go on for so long so
long I think cuz she was a woman no I
don't think it she looks so sweet and
innocent I just think it's the it's the
eyes like she just looks so innocent and
like she probably did more for the
hospital as well but someone said she
looked like my cousin I was like godam I
was like God damn it guys can um Can
someone fill me in I don't want your
name oh there was um a woman who her
name was Lucy Ley and she got arrested
for kill killing seven children um or
babies yeah she was a nurse all at the
same time um no it was over the course
of a couple years but they found out she
was dating a doctor like a married
doctor and they they think she was
killing the babies to get his attention
how um I she injected them with like
something okay yeah it was like the
wrong it was for his attention yeah kind
CU he would he would he would like help
her with them when they would go down
south or whatever
oh yeah no but I think social media has
made us
insane yeah especially because we pay
more attention to it yeah well I think
it's like we're all just so addicted to
it and it's like when when the social
media and I I really think there's going
to be women with a lot of mental health
issues in like 10 years because I think
when the attention like they're less
attractive they get older and it's like
when the attention starts to go I just
think a lot of women are going to go
nuts I think that's how we see life that
we see other people's lives we see
Snippets of happiness and that's what we
kind of Chase and that's not how
everyone's life is yeah we got to learn
to live in the moment more and just
spend days off for social media
completely and just appreciate what you
have like your family your home you know
the small things I think everyone I
think everyone needs therapy yeah that's
true oh no I think that makes you worse
no I feel like I feel like I disagree
with you I feel the best cause of action
for all this is just the throwaway you
found well I
actually this actually this wouldn't
help me personally but sometimes I'm
like if you had a brick Naka right now
you would be so much hear me out hear me
out ban women ban women off of social
media it makes us too crazy I think the
men can kind of handle it is it SN
t-shirt what is this the next t-shirt
well you know I don't want to push this
one too much I make money off of it but
but I was like you know I think that
might be a net good but I was like we
would find a way back on you can you can
keep us off but okay therapy you think
it's a good thing um yes mhm yes it's
definitely changed my view on life okay
w why how um I've had a I've had a
really rough upbringing abusive
background um Dad used to beat me U my
mom was an alcoholic um and I had like
six years of therapy and I always used
to see my glasses like half empty mhm
rather than half four so what did you
see before like what was the difference
between you six years it's hard to
explain it but I used to see everything
as black and white mhm like the world
was just black and white and now it's
sort of got color back so now I can see
things in a positive light which is it
was really difficult before and um you
know like when you tell people that they
just don't get it until they experience
it m um which is like depression and
just sadness just general sadness um but
I think fby helped me understand why
things happened and how things happen so
the why is and the who so all the
questions that I've got over the six
years of therapy really help me
understand who I am who my uh my my my
parents are um why they did the things
they did and why I am why I am and why I
make decisions so there was loads of
questions answered which now help me
navigate moving forward in life just
just day-to-day things just I can now
understand why everything is happening
and I can change it actively MH if I
want to therapy saved my life yeah what
same I saved my life too what what what
what was your experience so um I went
through about a depression you actually
s of this year bring the mic up um and
yeah made attempts on my life and W from
there I went into therapy and um yeah
changed the way I see things change way
I am yeah yeah yeah it's not a
competition but I've made like six
attempts on my life yeah oh wow yeah so
may this competition you
win so thank you I'll tell you I'll tell
you why I I don't believe in therapy now
I I think there's individual in yeah and
I thought it was stupid how long did you
do it for like a couple sessions and I
was like this is stupid exactly CU you
didn't give I'll tell let me let me let
me let me explain why and then you can
you can rebuttle so if you look into the
history of psychology it was started by
some of these big families
um and I I really think it's just
usually a way to make men more feminine
and and teach them how to communicate
like women in general and I think you
can see this because 90% of therapists
are women and I went I actually went to
school for psychology and those [__]
are crazy I'm like if these are the
women that are telling everyone how to
think oh my God now I do think there's
individual therapists that are good um
usually men I don't think it's like I
just think women don't look to solve
problems they look to they look to like
hear you and listen to you but not not
necessarily solve problems so the
therapists that I do think are good are
typically men not typically women which
is only 10% of therapists so and usually
what what I find is that especially
chicks will go to therapist for years
and then learn all these like think
everybody's a narcissist think
everyone's toxic in their life and I
really think therapy has replaced what
used to be a strong family structure
because you used to be able to go to
like someone in your household in order
to like fix problems but the issue is we
have such a [__] up like family
structure right now that people don't
have families to go to and they go to a
stranger instead and I think it would be
better if we could go to families
instead of go outside of it okay but you
do know like there's different types of
therapies like there's speak therapy
there's music therapy like there's
different forms of that which could help
I I think there's individual instance I
think male therapists are decent like I
think I think mostly I think some of my
best therapists have been me yeah I just
I just find that women are most of like
most therapists it's like 90% are women
and I just don't think women look to
solve problems they just look to like
listen which which is fine but I I just
think that it like you said like if you
don't have that family correct unit yeah
um who do you turn to you know what I
mean but now I'm more open to speak to
friends I'm more open to speak to I'm I
can speak to strangers about how what
I've been through find because you to
therapy um yeah it helped me open up to
to people and things but you see that's
like a more feminine trait and that's
why I say I think therapy like typically
makes men into women more feminine
because even that all be dead you know
I'm not saying it doesn't help in some
instances so you know I'm not trying to
like knock your
story but I've just I've just found that
like I I think that therapy tells men to
emote like women because typically like
women are the ones that need to talk
about their problems to feel better
where where men don't you know they'll
like fight it out or like you know just
in general right you think that that's
good I I think that making someone into
something they're not is bad and I think
making men into women is bad and we've
always been told that the feminine way
to do things is good okay also I would
like to add um typically I would say
instead of therapy what people should
seek out is mentorship so you want
someone that would teach you how to
attack problems in life and how to build
on positive steps each day so the reason
why a lot of people fall into depression
is usually for a few reasons one things
are not going right in their life or
they don't have direction that is
usually the reason why people fall into
depression so if you have someone that
can show you steps okay you know what
today go to the gym even when you don't
feel like going to the gym still do it
they push you you go over time you you
tend to build up small wins and then
with each small win you build up
character so this is the thing a lot of
men these days fall into the Trap of
going to therapy when you should
actually be
trying because as men we get our source
of um strength and our source of
motivation from actually um building
things making um little successes here
and there so you can't just sit in a
room and be talking about your feelings
and expect that I mean it could help it
could work for some people but gener a
lot of people it doesn't actually work
yeah I think it's better for people if
not just even men both men and women to
focus on doing things day by day and
getting small WIS and that way you can
come out of anything true I I actually
think this right here would help more
people than therapy now this is just my
personal opinion okay so these are just
pearls thoughts I think the natural
order of the world okay
God
men women
women
children all right so for those that
couldn't hear God men women children I
think most of the time when evil happens
or family dysfunction happens it's
because women think they're equal to
men so I think typically it's the women
trying to impose their will on men and a
lot of people with daddy issues actually
have mommy issues because the mom women
it's like our our violence is social
destruction so lot of people hate the
dad but it's really the mom and usually
when the family's out of order it's
because of the mom typically because the
mom either didn't listen to the dad she
didn't respect the dad or um
she or she socially like she told the
kids that the dad was bad that's what I
think most of the time I'm not saying
like this doesn't happen to there's evil
men there's evil women but if I had to
just go on a balance of probabilities
that's that's what I I think when
there's like family dysfunction and you
can always tell when there's family
dysfunction based on the children so
like an example I'll give you guys Will
and Jada Smith right I knew remember no
no okay I'll give you an example right
you guys do you remember when they were
a power couple and everyone loved them I
knew they were messed up because their
kids were so messed up like why why is
Willow and like whatever their names are
they're dress in like the opposite gen
like that's not normal right from like a
like I I mean I'm Pro like
traditionalism so I I I think that's
like a bad thing right and so I knew
they were messed up and so what what's
the problem with that family Dynamic uh
Jada thinks she's equal to Will and
she's constantly imposing her will on on
will and will listens to his wife now
seriously do you guys do you guys think
that like Will's idea was to do the open
marriage no no no it was hers right
correct like what happened in what
happened in the garden of Eve like like
Adam Eve had everything and she wasn't
happy and Adam listened to his wife and
I think that's what we're seeing in
society is women will have everything
they're not happy and then they listen
and then the men listen to their wives
and I I think you know when women have
the most Choice unfortunately we make
poor decisions you know again last
hundred years we've all chosen to be
[__] you know and we you know it's like
everyone's and and I do just I do the
show so much it's like everyone's got a
toxic ex-boyfriend everyone you
know you know everyone's dated a guy
that's cheated and it's like we just
don't we're we just are very loyal to
our feelings not it doesn't mean we're
like bad people it's just kind of how we
are we're loyal to our feelings We Men I
think men naturally and this is this is
out there okay I think men naturally
have God inside of them now again I'm
I'm a Catholic and the reason I think
this is because when men act B too bad
other men police them where when women
act bad other women encourage it right
so when women get fat we say you're so
beautiful you're a queen right when
women are hores we say don't [__] shame
but when men do drugs and they become
drug addicts other men say no don't do
that don't live your and they they'll
even admit that's wrong and you
shouldn't live your life like that so I
think men just are naturally better
people than women I know I know this is
like a crazy thought but yeah I think I
think I and I think knowing women in
male and female nature helps Society
more because it kind of explains our
Behavior a little bit better and I think
most of the time women that impose their
will on men that's when you get
the kids being messed up and you can
always see if a family Dynamic is good
based on the children yeah definitely
that's that's my therapy that's pearls
therapy you know yeah what do you do you
guys disagree with that or agree
completely agree really agree I thought
this is so wild I I've never had a room
agree with that you seem like you
disagree a little bit no no no no yeah I
agree so men are better people than
women to an I think they're stronger
people than women definitely I think men
are stronger as I said and it goes back
down to men leading when when women
allow men to lead and when men lead you
can see it in the children uh the family
Dynamics um the household you can see
the difference between a child who has
both parents at home yeah and the
difference between a child who has one
parent I can hear it in guys voices a
lot of the time cuz they like talk like
their mom because they like that's who
they had around them growing up not not
always I'm not like a 100% but a lot of
times like some guys will come on the
show and I can just like hear it MH um
Sometimes women too it's like the same
thing but it's like it's like more
obvious than men you know what I was
thinking too how our language sort of um
we tell on ourselves through our
language like if a woman acts like a man
it's not necessarily seen as a bad thing
like maybe in dating but it's like it's
not as looked down upon as if a man acts
like a woman like you say you're acting
like a woman right now like it's like
more of a negative than if a woman acts
like a man yeah yeah someone call me
sassy the other day
did it hurt your feelings a little bit a
little bit all right mascul me a bit
it's right yeah and I was just I was
just saying an opinion it what did you
say I was just like well okay I I just
moved on cuz I thought like if I said
anything about it I'd be more sassy
so I I don't care I'm all
right um
what what do you think is like the worst
ways that women try to control
men vagina oh oh yeah from sex yeah I
don't think that's that's always been
the main you say the worst way yeah like
how how do through the children that's
the worst thing a woman can do is try to
control a man through the that's one of
the lowest lowest things have you seen
that before um she's done it no never
ever ever ever never ever ever never
never never I completely disagree with
any woman who tries to um you know
jeopardize any relationship a child has
with their other parent cuz it's evil it
is evil and a child needs that parent
you know I I I think they should face
jail time yeah I think it's disgusting
if women that do do that and I have seen
it I mean I've seen it on TV and you
know I've seen it around um but that's I
think that's one of the lowest things a
woman could do yeah I thought definitely
I thought the worst way that you can
actually
like I feel like abuse is like the wor
best way especially like emotional abuse
or like in other cases like I don't know
that's the worst abuse that any man
could feel not being able to have access
to their children I want to change I
want to change my answer I think women
can emotionally abuse men but men can't
emotionally abuse women and I feel like
women are better at emotionally abusing
men like when we get the time to do it I
do yeah what do you think I think you
can emotionally abuse women yeah I don't
I don't think so no you could be tell me
why I'm wrong I just you can just yeah
you can say
things that chips away at you know
you're fat as a joke she fat she's ban
no she's kind of fat but it said as a
joke okay well then now you're just
truth telling and then after a while
it's just do you know what I mean but
that's what it goes back it goes back to
what you said though because you said um
you said before that um you know women
can't accept the truth yeah so it's like
you tell them in a jokey way
and it's the truth and it's like fix it
but then they like they
go it's horrible so I can't a joke as
well that's even more painful remember
you said we have to just take it
whatever the man says we just have to
take it and just take it on the chin and
just well I think that's I think I'm not
even give it back do you know what I
mean and then we all grow together do
you know what I mean you know and I'm
not even saying like anyone's going to
do it perfectly but I think the ideal is
just to listen right you know
communication yeah no no I think I think
more communication is like think about
this has a woman ever like communicated
with you and like then she's like oh I'm
happy now I solved the problem there's
the butt she's never going to be happy
we just there's always another problem
problem yeah so I I actually think we
should communicate less I think
communication is not the key women love
communication no cuz we just guys guys
if left like any Chick if we're just
left like like if the guy lets us
communicate as much as we want to we're
just never going to shut the [__] up
like we're just going to no I don't no I
don't think so I feel like communication
to an extent would make sense but I feel
like if you don't communicate as much to
your partner you're never going to
really know your partner it's just going
to be like two people who are going to
be mute in the house you know what's
crazy have you have you ever asked a
woman how their day was and it just goes
on on and on men hate
that're just it's the polite thing to do
but it just goes on and on it's crazy
really nothing situations as well
nothing happens but if you stop
listening it's all [__] mean it's all
just it's [__] up if you don't ask her
how her day was then you're not going to
win either why haven't you about my day
like PE said maybe less communication
more understanding more more
understanding okay imagine okay I had
this thought all right I want guys to
hear I want you to all right I think the
world would be a better place okay
imagine women got like a Talking
Stick okay and you get like two hours of
talk in a day or three whatever like we
could we could negotiate what it is and
the guy granted you how much you got to
talk based on your behavior for that day
so it's like if you had sex with him in
the morning you get 30 minutes you know
then it's like okay so you then it's
like okay you cooked him lunch or dinner
okay now you get another hour you see
like we just keep adding on what do you
do you guys think the world would be a
better place if we had that no I feel
like I feel like men will abuse the
stick though but like because of your
tightness you only get 15 minutes to
talk today like I feel like men would
abuse that no because they're going to
want like so they're going to abuse it
like more sex I get the more you can
talk I I think their true feelings would
come out no so if they don't want to
speak to you You' you'd find out very
quickly yeah yeah but they're going to
want sexual
favors but then what if you got your
hair done and you're like oh babe am I
okay to use like the stick to just tell
you like I just want to ask your opinion
on my hair maybe you can have like 15
minutes like off the bat it'll be nice
you know just a little venting session
about how your hair is and then no okay
maybe maybe 10 minutes for the day so
you don't talk too much no venting
session two minutes man 2 minutes 2
minutes you got to be quick with it I
heard a guy I I heard a guy say that he
felt like he could have a great
relationship with a woman that didn't
speak his language wow and that really
changed my view I was like Wow men
really don't like talking to us that
much the thing is women women talk about
communication so much but what I've come
to realize is it's not actually
communication women just want to talk
yeah so what it is is I think the stick
will work so well because what will
happen is women we start learning how to
actually communicate you've been
thinking about this
stick I feel like you've been thinking
about this stick I've pitched this
before oh so he's been thinking about
the stick I mean if you've only got 15
minutes you're going to get out the
important stuff in 15
minutes I think I think women are better
talkers but men are better
communicators yeah they just get
straight to the point they just get
straight to the point definitely Lally
while we like why we've got that time we
just want to get everything out oh yeah
remember the other day
but then I also feel like as woman
though like you know cuz like women
we're submissive to our man I feel like
we want to we want to make our man into
like our best friend in a way and we
want that person to like you know when
they come home like we want to be their
peace but we also want them to be like
our treasure if that makes sense I think
women do like naturally just cut
everybody off and just want to be by
their man men like I feel like that's a
part of being submissive as well because
realistically like there's some couples
out there when they have problems in the
relationships they don't actually go to
their friends or anything like they
actually just work about in their
relationship so I feel like in a way
that's what you naturally do for your
for your man like you will just cut the
world off for your man because you do
want to you know I mean you want to make
sure you can work on problems together
not everyone else can help you work on
those problems what did you say I said I
think that's the mistake like thinking
that your partner can be your everything
yeah yeah yeah absolutely you need you
need your friends separately he needs
his friend separately he needs his time
you need your time you need your things
yeah he needs his Hobbies that's where
when go wrong and you come you come back
together to an extent yeah you back how
much you how much pressure is like just
put them in just on a daily basis
there's a lot and then we go home and
then just get [__] yeah it's crazy you
guys have you guys do have a lot to deal
with true it's
crazy and then we don't have the Talking
Stick so we're
[__] feel like everyone's going to
take that stick idea from today I mean
you know once I I had a I had a
boyfriend and I was I was telling him a
story and he just looked at me he's like
I I don't
care I was like ah did you did you cry
did you cry in the yeah yeah a lot no I
just I'm so honest I'm really honest
yeah no I kind of respect it I just kind
of took it I mean my feelings were a
little hurt but I was like I maybe my
story wasn't as funny as I thought it
never is never is it never
is oh women think they're funny hey I'm
hilarious um okay I'm gonna Read Super
chats really quick then next we're going
to do another fun whiteboard exercise
where we're going to decide what
attention is acceptable and unacceptable
in a relationship is that before after
you get hit by a
pole that is that a bad joke oh all
right well poor woman all right so um we
have a $5 super chat if women have
speech limits they will learn side
language you know what it's true you
know we'll find another way we will find
another way you know you will do it too
we'll find another way I'm like side
language doesn't see side language
doesn't seem that hard find another way
or or a whiteboard yeah yeah or a white
board bloody white well well like act it
out literally like you've never seen
more motivated than a woman that just
wants to express herself you know what I
mean like women will express ourselves
we'll um
we'll go to like I mean car under did
the Underwood did the I dug my key into
the side of his PR you know like we key
his car and [__] when we could just say
hey I wish you didn't do that I wish you
well let's break
up you know you know anyway so we got a
$100 Super Chat I love to see doc the
magician looking really Hench what does
Hench mean like a British is that your
wife
what oh okay he's he's uh giving you a
compliment thanks um I heard he did you
I heard he used to be a dancer um are
your guests allowed to challenge
opinions I'm seeing a lot of passive
agreeing I said you guys could challenge
me right okay right you didn't know what
yeah I challenged you on a therapy yeah
yeah we could we could um all right
Emanuel Pearl forget Vegas and come to
Atlanta since Kevin Samuel's passed
there's a vacuum for this content and
there's Endless Options of cast members
to source for your live shows plus you
can go on a date with me um nonstop um
read TV the truth is that that
biologically women are only loyal oh we
read that one already I just wanted to
do we had another $100 Super
[Applause]
Chat um okay I'm going to refresh it
really quick oh this a sign language one
okay so next
I just love the Whiteboard I can
tell all right guys
so all right so since there's five of us
in here we're going to do a vote and
it's going to be really fun so we're
going to vote on if this is acceptable
in a relationship or
unacceptable
like I think we're going to do okay so
yes
no what are we laughing
about I I don't get it okay
so all right number
one Instagram is it okay for a girl to
have an Instagram in a relationship yes
yes
yes yes are we are raise your hand if
you think
yes yeah if she wants to I actually
think it's unacceptable oh my God oh God
what if she needs it for her business
well I mean there's exceptions but if I
think of a general rule Instagram's the
number one dating app so it's kind of
interesting because really okay now if
we if we go off the premise I'm going to
see if I can get you guys to my side
we're going to do a vote here if we
think of the premise that
Instagram that do we agree with the the
premise attention is to women as sex is
to men do you agree with that or
disagree disagree why because you can
get attention at home if you have a man
yeah not every woman not every woman
likes attention yeah speak to the mic oh
so not every woman likes attention Okay
so you would pick sex over
Beauty so if you if you had to pick
between um you get to look 21 forever or
you get to have sex with whoever like
the hottest guy on the planet forever
what would you pick i' have a SE
really you pick sex hell yeah okay would
you pick sex or beauty yeah cuz I feel
like sex makes you feel beautiful sex
makes you feel yeah if you've got
someone that thinks do you not agree no
I pick Beauty oh hell no I want if I
could look 22 forever one you can make
money off of that to like you two it's
like yeah I would I would pick that over
sex over like like sex with the hottest
guy ever or
beauty it depends if it's like how long
you're having sex for like is that the
same person you're having sex for for
the rest of your life was that just I
think it dep I think it depends on the
person as well like if it's Michael B
Jordan then yeah let's do it but if it's
not then okay Mars Chestnut okay um you
guys think sex is to women as to
attention or sex is to men as attention
is to women I think it depends on the
woman depends on the woman yeah I think
it's all women yeah this is just my my
personal thoughts but okay I'll I'll
tell you why I think that when all right
when a guy sleeps with a girl he gets
some sort of validation right women
don't get validation through sex we get
validation through guys like finding us
attractive through like being desired
that's true that's why I think it's
that's why I think it's different like
when we post a picture on Instagram
that's us getting validation through
being desired or when a man [__] a
bunch of chicks that's him like feeling
the most desired because he or you know
maybe he screwed the hottest chick right
it might for some guys it's just one but
you guys get the idea that's why I think
Instagram is cheating because you're
basically putting your beauty on display
for other
men but it's okay I can I can be
overruled I can be overed some some
women have put it on display for other
women some some people want to show the
kids like you know they want to show the
family that the kids are around I I
think if you look at most I think we
could pull up you guys' Instagram Pro
profiles and I think it'll probably look
like a dating app a little bit we could
we could do it it'll be fun if you want
I don't think you should put mine to be
H this we could we could later later
Bic you know um all right so we could we
could anyone change their opinion or
same opinion still acceptable or
unacceptable acceptable acceptable all
right I I won't sway you today it's all
right all right um next no it makes
sense going are you on my side now no
Instagram I don't think women should
have an Instagram wow all right well
okay he's which depends on Instagram
yeah that's what I'm
saying I mean if you to pull up my
wife's Instagram it's the it's there's
nothing
yeah all I'm sure it's about her daily
life or moment want show shouldn't she
want to tell you about her date like why
does the world need to know about
probably just she's probably got a
certain amount of friends in there that
she wants to share her daily life with
instead of putting still validation
though it yeah but what if it's for her
business exact it's her business as how
much okay but it's not how much her
women really in a month you know the
average woman makes like 500 a month and
only fans we can't even sell sex like
most women don't make any
money you know what I mean like it maybe
if she has a real business you know yeah
if it's a real business but it's like do
we really but even then do you need to
post your face no depends what your
business is that's true what are you
selling but then again yeah it depend
you could be to selling beauty products
you could be your post other people you
could be your brand you don't have to
post yourself though yeah but you could
be the brand or it could be homemade
made stuff that you want to but you
don't have to post yourself post herself
she post it could proba a i we're going
to use Kim Kardashian that's like
the why women shouldn't have an
Instagram why cuz she sells sex
literally she literally her brand is
based on her sex tape like that's her
life oh yeah well and have you seen have
you seen her Instagram is that look how
look how much money she's made from that
is women is is is money worth her her
kids mental health no not at all okay so
so what has that led to for her does it
seem like the outcomes for her children
are going to be good when we got the one
kid like dancing with ice spice depends
if you're looking at a bank account or
if you're looking at well it depend well
it depends what matters to you money
money or mental health like money or
your values right cuz yes him a little
bit I mean I I personally think they are
quite quite put together family
obviously they have their problems like
everyone else my my personal opinion on
that family is love each other no they
don't they don't everyone in that family
is a money Pig like none of them people
have anything substantial the only
person that has something substantial is
Kylie and Kendall none of them have
anything that's grown from the mud all
they do is stem off that woman's tape
literally there's nothing else to them
well and and they're all single mothers
literally all of them I think ka's all
right there you
go who's KAIT Bruce Bruce he was a man
he used to be a man and now he's a woman
oh you got the
joke all right we got all right we got
Instagram
okay um all
right
clubbing clubbing if you're clubbing
with your partner no like alone alone no
never depends what age you are as well
yeah if you're young I had a chick on
the show that was really confused why I
said she shouldn't club with children
anymore like she had kids I was like
maybe it's time to spend out like not go
to the club anymore yeah depends what
age you are think if you're a young mom
so who says um acceptable who says yes
oh wait I put this in the wrong one yes
depending on what stage you are in your
relationship stop women should stop
going into the club yeah I'm asking is
it cheating or not cheating like is is
it yes it's acceptable no it's not
acceptable not it's not all right so
raise your hand if you think think no
not acceptable traditional clubbing yeah
like yeah I mean but bars and stuff
depend bars you think it's acceptable or
not acceptable go to Club if she's in a
relationship no no no no it's fine with
to Bar yeah bars and stuff if you
depends what you're doing you could be
going to your you could be going to your
a CL yeah going to your sister's
birthday birthday to a club like where
you going to not go because you're in a
relationship you could go to a bar yeah
you let stay at a restaurant and go
home all right so since we approved
Instagram I want to know
selfies yes what's wrong with selfies is
it is it is it like a type of selfie
just a you know face just like just your
face that's cool is it is it a pretty
face though cuz if she's ugly she can
post as much as she wants that's F no
she's she's she's going to be with you
right so she's got to be a pretty girl I
mean ug always I mean yeah man I don't
judge you know okay let's say yeah she's
she's a pretty chick yeah so selfies yes
who says a selfie is okay fine I think
selfies are good like they're okay kind
of I'm in the middle with that one what
do you think I'm going to say no I'm
going to go hard no no selfies why
because you're advertising your beauty
why why why do they got to see you smile
she'll only be smiling for your man you
can't have nothing nice can you what if
she's not smiling I mean yeah why she's
wearing a turtleneck and she I just I
just want to know like what what's the
point like what is she going to get out
of like what is the point of posting it
I'm not going to lie it would be better
for a chick to post a selfie than a
woman who has a fat ass fat boobs
beautiful curves to post a full body
pick she's going to be more advertising
just because there's something worse it
doesn't make the selfie good but what's
wrong with
the that's like saying well I only did
only fans Not porn like no I don't think
I don't think it matters to be fair it's
like taking the question is what what
what is the point of posting the selfie
because yeah what you're not realizing
is I can easily compare that to someone
addicted to drugs like why are you
posting the selfie just to get that
dopamine hit of oh people like your
pictures why for what validation she
probably she probably wants to show off
that she she bought nice earrings she
got her hair done or you know she got
her make she got her makeup done still
validation could be that but at end day
why is she showing it off to strangers
but would it be better for would it be
better for a man to post a selfie is
itar get L
validation okay then so would it be
better for a man to post a full body
pick to obviously advertise his design
aware that that's we're saying the same
thing like it's an addiction if it's
that valid he's selling something like
he's selling the clothes or he's selling
like a fitness plan that's different but
if you're just posting it just so that
people can like it but this is the point
like you used to get all that validation
and attention from your man and not a
million strangers like I used to watch
like 1940s like wife tips and it was
like oh get some makeup on before your
husband gets home like have your hair
done so so you're like ready to see him
but now it's like women will get their
makeup done for Instagram but not their
husband they'll look half like homeless
but aren't we all seeking that
validation not just women no I think
that women seek out validation much more
than men partially because we can
but but my opinion I think women like
men seek sex so I that would the
equivalent of that to me would be men
having access to easy sex and taking it
I think yeah they probably would like if
you had that validation doesn't
necessarily come from the opposite sex
always like you could be um your friends
could be like oh cool picture like do I
mean it's um I think they could but I
would say typically women post for
attention from high status men that's
that's my opinion typically it's a yeah
I I think some women actually post for
other
women I I think that's the equivalent of
when women dress half naked and they say
they do it for themselves I just don't
really believe it that's why I still
have to ask like it's still to the same
point What's the difference between a
selfie and a full body pick if you get a
girl who's got ass curves boobs and she
takes a full body picture if she taking
a selfie of just literally just like the
face just if you if you were going to
have a dating profile would you put a
selfie on it yeah that's the point
that's be point because because you're
get correct you're showing yourself and
that's the whole point is you're getting
validation from the opposite gender well
I actually agree with the lady on the
right I think women also post for other
women yeah we do because it's not even
like it's not even just for the
validation aspect it still ties back to
men because it's kind of like a
competition competition women are very
at the end of day it still ties back to
men but it's still like there's still
that competition between women because
women want to be able to post and have
other women validate them and say yes
you are beautiful but then he still ties
back to validation the latest handbag or
the latest shoes or the latest top and
oh what's their name's got that you know
women for women too yeah but it's but
he's right but it's all to compete for
the guys so it's still ties back to the
man to an extent to an extent I mean I
wouldn't I wouldn't look
I think a lot of men and women haven't
really thought about it like this but
again I think most women today are like
basically this is the average
chick and she's got her phone in her
hand you see right there and yeah I just
think because of the phone she's getting
usually she's got like 10 guy friends um
she's getting like 10 million likes from
all the guys on Instagram messaging her
every day trying to date her so it's
like we just have this constant
validation so we just think we're so
amazing and hot true where the men are
just told they ain't [__] all the time
so it's like not a validation it's not
equal
validation and yeah so I think when we
post the Selfies it's just we're getting
all this attention from the other people
and I think we should avoid that if we
can so I'm gonna say no all right so who
says yes to the Selfies raise your hand
I still say yes so yeah say I'm
overruled today it's all right
though
selfies what was but going back to your
dating question okay go ahead cuz I have
to ask if you if if I didn't post a
picture of myselfie on a dating app
would you be would any guy be more
attracted to a blank profile than an
actual profile with a picture on there
depends on your
bio do you go for people's bios more
than they well I've never seen one
without a selfie have I fair enough so
you would need a selfie no but but the
point is you're on a dating app for the
men so obviously it's acceptable for to
post your picture there but if you claim
that you're not on Instagram for men
then why are you posting your
picture because you could be like I said
Kardashian but like you could just be
posting it for business
purposes I see where everyone's coming
from but realistically like you want to
kind of know who you speaking to like
why would you not want to know who
you're speaking to I'm sure that also
goes into how to be attract how to
attract to someone unless you're like
you know you've got a type of would
would I say sapio sexual would you be
sapio seexual okay but I understand but
like if it's like so for instance on my
Instagram I have just four posts on
there and I'm a videographer as well as
a producer but like I I make videos but
even though I make videos I don't
necessarily post so many videos on there
yeah I used to post a lot when I was
actually doing my videography and doing
a lot of edits but now I don't really
post anything because it's like what's
the point I'm not just going to put a
selfie so my point is it's not like you
can't have a couple of pictures in there
but when you're posting selfies like
today you post a selfie tomorrow you
post a selfie that's what we're talking
about we're not just talking about
having like the odd selfie here and
there okay someone that's just an
attention SE yeah that's to be posting
all the time like that's too much going
on a Instagram
all point I think I think my point is
like men used to get like the best of us
because all of our validation and
attention was tied to making one guy
happy so that was like our Focus but now
it's like you see these women you know
they have have their kids and they're
like I saw a video the other day of a
woman on her phone and the guy took her
baby cuz she was paying attention to her
phone think I and he just he just he
gave it back to her but it was just to
like point out that she wasn't paying
any attention to her kid and I just
think like social media has just made us
like crazy to the point where we're like
dressing up for Instagram but not like
our like we'll we'll dress up for like
you'll see wives dress up for a girl's
night out but not for their husband when
he gets home and it's like almost like
the internet's getting the best of us
and not the people around us so it's
kind of just a weird dynamic I don't
know guy friends is that acceptable or
unacceptable unacceptable being you're
in a relationship it's kind of based
right what do you think unacceptable
it's unacceptable even if you're out of
a
relationship cuz everyone's try to
[__] I think it I think it depends like
you know my girl friends two of them
obviously they are um they're um
homosexual so you know I don't really
have a problem with them however other
other guy friends I wouldn't really say
if I'm in a relationship I would keep up
with them to be honest even out of a
relationship just resp just respect like
just respect you
wouldn't just out of respect you
wouldn't every guy's trying to [__]
that's what say wait would the gay
friends count like would they be okay
yeah no why I I don't have any they
don't want any P they just want the
DS are the worst theyve to
no no worse because then the woman goes
to them to spill gossip and gay friend
is not going to be on the man's side
either way I think I think it depends on
what type of category they are um let me
just be careful what does that mean I
feel like it depends what category you
are like if there are someone who's a
bit intensely feminine then of course
they're not going to be um they're not
going to really take the man's side but
if there's somebody who can see both
which is like masculine and
feminine either way the right friend
will always point you in the right
direction always put you in the place if
you're in the wrong realistically so I
don't really see as much of a problem I
wouldn't trust I wouldn't trust gay
friends around my girl simply because
because there's a lot of things that I
know women don't think about first of
all you know how women get with their
gay friend there's almost No Boundaries
you you tell them every single secret
they they look through your phones I
might have pictures on there of my naked
self on there and then your it sounds
like you know from experience cuz this
is too much going on this is too much
going on very very in depth literally
logic I'm I'm thinking like a man I'm
telling you what think about so it's
like there are so many things that women
just don't think about because you're
just in the middle of oh yes my
girlfriend think about knock on effect
that's the thing and then now when I
mention it you're saying no it doesn't
have to be like an experience it's just
logic like if you really think about it
and that's the reason why like really
and truly you shouldn't have too many
friends that are so close to you when
you're in relationship because when you
have so many people outside of your
relationship that you go to with
problems then you're just opening the
doors more problems it's true true agree
it's very true absolutely agree that's
why it's like in in your relationship it
would be best to like solve problems to
together rather than telling other
people your problems like it would make
more sense yeah yeah I've had friends
advise me oh you need to leave him no
you need to leave him and then when you
when when you've left him they're like
nowhere to be seen literally like yeah
the problem during a Fallout you'll go
and vent to your friend and then you'll
get back with the guy and your friend
now thinks you your guys yeah exactly
You' let you've let her know way too
much that's a big one in a way as well
you offer you make your friends offer an
opinion when you tell them more about
your relationship and they start having
an opinion on your person as well cuz
remember some friends don't want to see
you happy remember that some friends
want you to be single just like somebody
want some friends want you to be
miserable just like them like and that's
just a truth don't forget when you're
venting to a friend you're venting the
negatives yeah you're not speaking about
the good your your friend's just hearing
all these
negatives and then and then when you get
back together exactly it's an issue yeah
yeah
exactly okay
Quest um all right so guy friends raise
your hand if you think yes okay so this
is a consensus no not okay venting to
someone like another guy there just a
woman venting into guy a woman venting
into absolutely no no no cuz he's going
to want to sleep with you single women
friends single women friends when you're
in a relationship when you're in a
relationship what's your what's your I
know I see you have thoughts on this
when you're in a relationship or when
you're not in a relationship
ship when you're in relation when you're
in relationship in relationship what do
you think about single women friends I I
think you should I think you should not
wait not being people are single but you
have less let's let him speak I want to
hear what he's got to say no I'm I'm
cool with that it's just how much gets
gets passed on and how much the event
and stuff because you tend to find
single women friends kind of want the
friend to be single with them yeah
they're a bad influence yeah that's true
I want to I want to know from the guys
is there any acceptable venting as women
like we typically vent to somebody who's
acceptable to vent
to family family AB I don't know I don't
know about that I don't think family is
I think I think depends on the issue
mild venting is fine so you fent to I
don't know I think you should just keep
your your problems in house I think if
you're a woman you vent to your dad cuz
your dad's going to tell you the truth I
feel if you're a man you vent to your
mom m that's what I thought but then
don't you think like when you vent to
these people they're going to build
their own perception on your partner I
feel like you really shouldn't give them
a type of like nobody I don't think you
should I don't think you should get
anyone even to say so
therapist yeah but remember sometimes I
think your therapist definitely or your
Mentor I think you should come on a Punk
podcast and venty talk L but then your
business is going to be out like we did
today hey
women shouldn't vote yeah oh my go so
venting no it's a unanimous single women
who says single women friends okay raise
your hand no um I don't know I would say
don't completely cut them off because
they're your friends your if that's your
true but hold on have you have less
access to them because you're having a
you have a different lifestyle you know
I don't so it could be conflict of
interests so I wouldn't say completely
just be like oh you're not my friend no
more cuz I'm in a relationship you know
you're just going to slowly cut slowly
just be like okay I'm over here doing
this you're over there hi
bab I'm not saying cut them off but you
have you've got it's like when you grow
up you you go and work work going to
slowly ghost your friend yeah but not in
a bad
way you know you know it makes sense
though it makes sense because you see
when women have like a bad time
especially like for example married
women like married woman will ever go to
a single friend because their single
friend has more time they'll go to them
and be like oh he did this to me and he
pissed me off whatever but realistically
if you're someone who's single and you
know you're not really like going out
there to go and find someone to marry or
settle down with you are going to give
your friend [__] advice and I'll be
honest with you I've been the person
who's given [__] advice but
realistically you can't you can't give
advice to people who are in a union like
you can't cuz you don't even know what
that is you don't even know what their
at least you at least you know it cuz
like women always think we give the best
advice I'll hon horrible advice I take I
take I take relationship advice from
women that are married because I feel
like if I take advice from my single
friends they're going like oh city girls
we're going to be outside we're going to
do this but I'd rather like have friends
who are single that want to be
encouraged to actually have a union and
I'd rather take advice from women who
are actually married rather than single
friends who are going to you know want
me to be outside like that's just dead
yeah if you're a single girl and you
want to get married the best thing to do
is have four friends that are married
you know they say if you have friends
that marriage you're going to become the
one half of the time half of these girls
like you know some men might not see it
but they're miserable they look nice
when you see them but they're miserable
they're upset like they're not happy so
it would be better off to just go to
people who are actually in better
situations than yourself so single women
raise your hands if you think single
women friends are okay yeah if they're
trying to get married if they're trying
to get married yeah okay what you no no
no you know I just like say I just like
taking away our rights someone to say
no um trying to think if there's
anything else I wanted to add I think we
covered most of it any anything you guys
think we should add to the list of
things to ask
about I'm open to suggestions what about
what about like um taking advice from
like your mom and your mom's like in a
weird situation like no no no I think no
I think mothers mothers it's the natural
order what about what about girls trips
oh God yeah what about when you're in a
relationship and you have like men's
trips and girls trips is the guys
allowed to go on their trips and the
girls not or can you both be your own
hear me out hear me out hear me out I
think the men should be allowed to go on
the boys trip my but you would say that
but the girls can't why would you even
say that okay okay all right hear me out
you guys are thinking the worst you're
thinking the worst you know my brothers
go hunting and four-wheeling and they
have a great time I think men hold on
wait wait wait what does that mean
they they go like H deer okay all right
cool they kill some you know and they go
snowmobile like I think men have to be
around other men like I think they get
too feminine if they're just around
women all the time I think like I don't
know there's something where guys just
like love to be around each other and
like but when women get around each
other we lead towards destruction now
I'm not saying he might he might screw a
a stripper on that girl's trip it
mighten he is going to screw a stripper
on that trip but like it's like all
right it's a stripper you can get
through it you know it's not like he got
a girlfriend it's really hard to screw
strippers just so you know yeah I mean
maybe maybe just
a wow but but here's the thing if if
your man can screw a lot of girls on his
man's trip then he probably can do that
without even going on the trip that's
true so you already have that on your
that's true but for the women like her
going away is just literally giving her
a ticket to go do whatever so what if
the man is not going on Hunting what if
he's going to magal or Marbella for like
a little party holiday he's going to
more than likely go out and shag no no
I'm not lying like he's going to more
likely shag I think you underestimate
how hard it is for men to get sex not
unless he's unless he's really hot it's
really not that easy so hard it's not a
joke he might try I won't lie to you he
he very well may tr% he's going to try
but then it's it's just him having a
good time is it having a little bit of
banter with the the boys you know what I
mean but they need to get out of their
system I think all men need to get out
of the system yeah and like honestly
it's like I think we've been brainwashed
to think that a guy cheating on you with
a stripper is the worst thing ever or
like a [__] oh no I don't think it's
like it's like you know he he was
offered the easy sex you'll get over it
you know it's not like a
mistress but I I have weird I have weird
but anyway so um we're going to we're
going to make them separate
so all right girls trips who says yes we
should be able to go yeah yeah yeah
should come on cuz we're not going to go
we're not just going to go on a trip to
to have sex like we don't really do that
but the problem is the difference is
everybody devious what about
Spar doesn't really let's be real no no
no no no no no for the right guy though
for the right guy because we We Like
Girls We Thrive off emotion like we
don't so imagine if you meet a guy that
sparked those emotions but if you're in
a good relationship and you've g a girl
CH okay I did interviews at a Chris
Brown concert and I asked the chicks I
asked the chicks I said hey um I asked
them if they're in a relationship those
chicks as well yeah and I asked like if
Chris Brown wanted to fly you out for
the weekend would you go and they all
said yes pretty much all of them
regardless of if they had a boyfriend or
and the difference is for average chicks
you know there was just that rumor that
that podcaster slept with um Drake you
remember do you know what I'm talking
about oh about yeah that's like an
average looking normal chick normal
chicks have access to these top 10 20%
of guys yeah so that's a reality out
here thinking they're tens it's crazy
like six could actually sleep with one
of these athletes like the top 1%
athlete entertain whatever it is so
that's why I think we can't go because I
think there's just too many people
trying to sleep with us all the time
what about a spa trip the average girl
that's relationship not going on find a
guy like she might not be going but I
think we go for validation I think the
even the girl in the relationship might
put on a nice outfit to look nice and
get the attention and I don't I don't
think that's necessarily like cheating
or abnormal right but like I think girls
get more high off of getting a bit of an
attention on night out then go into into
a guy's room and with him so you agree
attention is to women as to sex is
to yourself there I can't lie you put
yourself there no I'm saying I'm no but
I'm saying if if that's what it is like
everybody likes a compliment we're human
who doesn't like a
compliment but the point is the problem
is when they give you the compliments
and they're trying to have sex with you
like okay imagine if your guy went into
a room with a bunch of women trying to
have sex with him
would you be perfectly okay with that
absolutely
not but they're not a girl's not going
on a trip to go with a bunch of guys oh
yeah but he says baby girls he say so he
says baby you know I'm not going there
to get laid but there's all these people
that want to sleep with me all the time
but here's the here's the the reality
guys want quantity women want quality
right right that's what I'm saying the
guy will go on the trip to try and get a
bunch of chicks the woman on the other
hand will go on the chick on the trip to
try and get that one right guy qu that's
a single woman that's a single woman a
woman that's a single woman is a woman a
woman a woman who has a loving husband
at home she has the kids and she is
loving her situation I think personally
woman will only Break Free if they're
not in if they're not in a good
situation you literally just explain the
most perfect marriage which doesn't
exist that's fine but if the situ if the
situation you literally just said a
woman who has a loving husband at home
who is loving her situation who has the
perfect relationship that doesn't bro
I've still slept with those women
exactly how did you I'm not saying it
it's never happened but out of 10 so
even what what is the guarantee that at
the moment she's going on that trip she
is in the Rel I'm not saying that I'm
guarantee anything I'm not saying that
she has to be in a in like a perfect
situation she has to be in a situation
that makes sense she's in a situation
that makes sense she's never going to
have a reason to do that but every day a
woman wake up to and relationship will
make sense and the very next day it
doesn't make sense yeah look men fall
men fall in love with the women women
fall in love with how you make them feel
so if they're not feeling on that day
it's a different story okay that's fair
enough it could even have nothing to do
with the man it could just be how she's
feeling that day she could have just
gotten she just could have like she's
about to get her period she's pissed off
about Goda but I just think if a woman
is in like a good setup I don't think
she's really going to go on a trip and
go sh somebody else I think we're too
unstable okay it's like you've never
you've never seen a chick do something
out of
character plus you're even forgetting
the fact that she's going on a trip with
other girls where there's social
influence single on there alcohol not
all the time no but but the point is
alol there's going to be other girls
egging her on to probably do something
that Shea sing but that's where it comes
that's where it comes down to like what
I said like when I said that if you're
single as somebody who's single you
shouldn't be around women who are in
very good unions or good marriages you
should really and truly you shouldn't
even be influencing them you should be
allowing them to influence you to find
your husband you shouldn't really be
going somewhere influencing them it's a
her mentality
thing I wouldn't no it's just peer
pressure is it I actually truly believe
that women have like something that
could be compared to like a hive mind so
when you're in groups you all tend to
think Al like and I've noticed a lot on
this podcast cuz you have a bunch of
girls and then PE will ask a question
and what the first girl says there are
many girls just keep repeating it over
and over and over again that's so cheeky
hey have you ever seen a h night Jesus
Christ that is mental a h night is crazy
so boys trips I'm going to say let the
boys go yeah man you would say the boys
go
espe she's a good woman that that serves
her man takes care of the home makes
sure the kids are good loves on her
husband publicly shows him affection why
can't she go with a trip on a trip with
her sister and her and her best friends
okay I'm going to I'm going to the same
the same reason you he your husband
shouldn't let you go to work because
because I'll stay
home exactly I mind that exactly because
because when we get into certain
situations we just I just you know the
fact that they convinced us we were like
at home we didn't have to work and like
we had all this automated stuff and they
convinced us to go work and be [__] I
just like we can't be trusted so it's
their fault then it's not ours then is
it yeah no I think we should I think we
should
switch we should take accountability for
our some people that ruined it for
others and those people ruined it for
y'all well well we all ruined it for
ourselves I'll tell you why all we had
to do and I thought about this the other
day I'm like do you know how powerful a
22-year-old virgin in shape would be on
the dating Market she would have so many
options imagine and none of us thought
of
that we just like like who who do most
women lose their virginity to is it some
random oh no and you could get that is
so Criminal maybe it's a college
boyfriend High School boyfriend whatever
it was but it's like you could have
gotten like a ring out of that you could
have get lifelong commitment and we CH
like none of us had the idea to wait
till we were 22 and and marry basically
anyone in the west because it's cuz you
look all influenced by cardi B in that
do you know what I mean so cardi B is
not in this equation she she did what
she had to do just wet wapped everywhere
she did what she had to do all right
boys who says yes waps everywhere who
says yes to the boys trips I say yes
yeah long as we can go on the girls TR
all right no no I I said we we voted
that one though but yeah thank you guys
what a what a great team
effort really what a fun what a fun
group
today I'm gonna read I'm going to read
super chats hold
on also guys um if you like my shirt and
you also think that women shouldn't vote
you know I'm to I'm going to give you
guys a couple policies that were passed
in the last hundred years since women
got choice and really we're 55% of the
population so you know our vote really
influences and dictates directions Mo or
elections most of the time um so a
couple policies we legalized abortion
yep now we kill our kids legally then we
also um made it we we gave women the
children so we take your kids from you
yep no fault divorce was passed after
women got Choice um all these government
benefits if you look at work regulations
that's women's Choice think about it HR
would disappear tomorrow if women didn't
have a say wow think about that all the
HR departments would be gone um and so
yeah I just think women should not vote
so if you guys agree with me uh the link
is the audacity network. store that's
the audacity network. store the link is
in the description go get yourself a
shirt and it also helps support the
channel um anyways so all right super
chats also guys like the video uh what
are we at we're at 588 likes I think
unless this is not refreshed but we need
to get to a thousand likes help help a
check out there's over a thousand of you
watching so all right so uh Magic M uh
Pearl is great at hammering points in
different ways without providing a good
reason just keeps switching up the way
she's hammering the point
um Emanuel Chon the best person for
women to vent to is her boyfriend's mom
for one it's more productive than
talking to her biest relationships the
man's mother will be objective and keep
the two together uh just the other life
women only have friendenemies not
friends they're always trying to up
themselves over their friends magic M
what's the crap about gender unification
be unique Elliot Morris on Anton
Daniel's podcast they had a transsexual
male that claims he slept with every
single one of his female friends he said
eventually they get drunk and want to
try something different magical M uh
thank you for the Super Chat the just
the other life notice the difference
between branding um from men and women
women tend to use their face as the
brand however men oh wow however men
name business based on location the type
of business and men tend to have a
generic image of the business wow that's
so
true how like women when we have a
business we use our face for it
where men it's like like Elon Musk it's
like X you know you know what I mean
like Bill Gates he's not but Kim Kardash
wow it's very
true um yeah but that's the other thing
guys we just monetize Beauty like a lot
of women think we're just killing it in
the workforce and just like breaking all
these barriers but really most of us are
just treated special because we're hot
yeah we go into sales retail waitress
all the ways that we can like monetize
Beauty and that's why you see women over
the age of like 30 roughly are Income
kind of plateaus and it just continues
to Plateau for a lifetime um it used to
be because of kids but you know we stop
we kind of stopped having those as a
group so uh we're starting to not
anyways um all right if women will have
speech limits oh they will learn side
language okay let me refresh
it um one more
[Music]
time
okay
so now I just want to I'm curious from
the single
people
what what is your plan for the rest of
your life yeah so um I I need to I need
to know how old you are so 19 years what
are you late
30s late 30s okay so so question um and
I just asked I asked this more just I
asked this more just cuz I'm curious cuz
I feel like under 40 it's just like a
lot of single people so I'm just curious
like do you want to be married again I'm
getting married again okay oh jeez she
said it she said it okay and do you
think that's going to be to this guy
you're in a distance relationship with
that's the plan that's well not the plan
like do does he want to marry you is he
expressed interest what's his like
timeline on it um he wants to get
married as soon as possible but as I we
haven't been dating for that long so I'm
still trying to where does he live him
so he's back and forth from here to New
York okay I actually met him when I was
back home in Jamaica I what you going to
say on a girls
trip okay so like what and I'm curious
what information would you need to know
about him in order to marry
him
um that's a good question actually
um there's a lot I mean there's a lot
more that I want to know like I just I
I'm kind of getting to know his family
values now um he also has two children
like myself um and and all the reasons
he he wants to be married do you want to
be married just to say you're married or
you know do you want to be married just
to have someone on your arm or what why
do you why do you want to be married I
want to be married because I was married
before and I liked believe it or not I
loved being married um it's something
that I loved um I'm very family
orientated I have a huge family um so
for me it's just natural for me to be
married again cuz it's something that I
did like being not with the person that
was married to anymore what do you what
do you think a guy gets nowadays out of
marriage that he doesn't get from a
long-term
girlfriend
um good question again um so I would say
with a long-term girlfriend you you you
never have the assurity of that if
that's really the person that's you're
going to spend your life with obviously
if if you're having children you want to
make sure that you're having a children
in a family unit family home do you do
you think he get do you think he gets
that assurity from a wife yes how so
when they leave because it's a bit more
difficult for you to leave if you're
married right it's more you have more of
a title even though it's just a title um
because people live in a home for a long
time I mean I wasn't I wasn't married
for years know years into my
relationship before so you can still
live in a home and be technically living
like your Mar married but you know you
don't have to have that thing saying
you're married but you have more of
assurance that you're married well
wouldn't you couldn't um couldn't you
argue that there's more of an incentive
for women to leave since we're paid to
do
it oh what in terms of divorce yeah
because you I mean you can get alimony
you can get child support um you can you
know I've heard of women taking the
house you know yeah I me in this day day
and age it's more it's more going that
way marriage because obviously yeah you
get a woman gets half of everything but
now I'm hearing it's it's vice versa now
right so if the woman's earning more
it's definitely not still sign a prup no
well you can sign a prup but um
basically women can claim they're under
duress when they signed it yeah and yeah
yeah you can wait I'm sure there's like
I feel like this more applies to America
though
that men can actually get like money out
of their well they can but it's the
exception it's not the rule and
typically like when women get money out
of the men it's like or when men get
money out of the women it's nowhere near
what women get out of the men just like
typically trust me women if if that
started happening across the board oh
the laws would be changed so quick yeah
you don't think imagine if that um so
would you be okay with like a long-term
relationship where you live together and
you never got married yeah I'll be okay
with that as well because I've I've done
that before but you know it's nicer to
especially if you like you're doing
things like buying property together and
things like that it's nicer for you to
be married right than just being in a
relationship and don't know what's going
to happen and and and I'm I'm curious if
you were with someone would you expect
them to cover 100% of the bills or would
you absolutely not okay what would you
expect him to cover I would expect like
I said I would expect a man to probably
do more than the woman in terms of
financially but I do think a woman
should have access to her own just just
coming from experience I think a woman
should always have access to her own
money um but I do think a man should
financially provide for for that woman
and the family right so like what
percentage of the
bills um I would say a woman should just
take care of herself ha and I'm joking
I'm joking I'm joking but yeah I do
think I do think a man should lead in
terms of paying the majority and
providing for the family but a woman
should be able to say he go babe you
know so what what percent of the
bills I would
say 70% to the men okay 70% you'd pay 30
yeah um what what do you think of if you
were married to a guy could you hand
your paycheck to him yes especially if
he's taking care of house and home okay
and I know that he's a provider take it
have it so you'd be okay with like a
joint bank account and like he's in
charge of it you don't have any access
oh have no access at
all I'm just curious how far you I'm
just curious how I'm just curious I'm
not saying you should I'm just curious
how far you no I think a woman should
definitely have access to some money
yeah yes I just you know what's
interesting I think it's interesting
that we trust men to raise children but
we don't trust men and we and we trust
men with our bodies but we don't trust
men with our money like we always feel
like we need a backup in case it doesn't
work out yeah I mean that's life
sometimes life hits you right so you it
is a smart thing to do to have a backup
yeah okay yeah okay I think we shouldn't
have backups cuz that way you'll just
stay and you'll just take all the you
just no you just got to figure it out
yeah I think um and women I think they
should kind of ban us from credit cards
too oh yeah they're disgusting those
things yeah well we just we spend so
much we just swipe them yeah we should
we should you know you when you think of
History you got to think of like they
had reasons for these things and you
know they always talk about a women
couldn't have bank accounts well there
is a reason there's a reason why have
you seen the way we
spend we have um 80% of consumer buying
decisions are made by women so we're
spending all the money even though we
make less literally just for a click of
a button it's like you see something
online you're like oh I that another
extra outfit won't hurt like and it's
just you're putting all these things
you're like how did I spend $1,000 it's
like what where did it
go um okay so what's your plan for your
life do you want to be married yeah I
want to be I want to have a strong union
with someone I want to be married I want
to have kids and
um I want to have a farm with my partner
as well a farm have you have you worked
on a farm yeah partly did when I was a
young girl okay um how how what did you
do um fed chickens fed sheep okay and
how old were you I was like eight okay
so you fed chickens and sheeps when you
were eight now you want to live in a bar
yeah I want to I want I want to like you
know just kind of like get away from the
world and kind of like yeah have that
okay um so where are you going to find
this farmer
man wow it could be any man I could I
could even speak him into it's a good
idea but but that's what I see for
myself and you're 26 like when do you
want to be married potentially I would
want to be married by the time I'm 28
okay and how long would you have to date
a guy before you can marry him um
probably like a year sorry I need to I
need to I need to pause I need to this
line of
conversation you
said you said you could even speak him
into it you see like you literally
didn't even learn anything from
everything it's not no it's not like
yeah because you understand how much
your language actually tells about what
you truly believe because you might not
see it but if you car if you keep
carrying that sort of language it will
actually affect your actions so you try
to speak a man into running a
farm oh no that that no the point the
point I'm just trying to make is that if
you have that kind of mentality you're
probably going to pick the wrong kind of
guy no because you shouldn't be with any
man that you're going to have to be
telling him the ideas of how he's going
to progress in life a man should be the
one that has his direction and you
should follow oh no it wouldn't be mean
okay maybe that was a wrong choice of
words but it wouldn't been mean
necessarily speaking into it it would be
more or less bringing up the idea and
kind of just seeing where can go the
idea kind of see kind of seeing where we
can go cuz if it comes to a point of for
example we buy land I would obviously
want to predominantly have a farm If he
if he says that he doesn't agree then
I'm I'm just speaking from the point of
a man because the point is if it's not
his idea
yeah there is no way on Earth he's going
to be 100% fully into it and if he's not
100% fully into it he's going to fail
yeah that's the point so like when women
bring these ideas to men and they think
they're doing him a favor usually you're
actually taking him off his own destiny
of where he should be looking
at just my point well and sometimes I'm
not going to lie I think like if you
wanted to live on a farm you'd be like
working on one yeah fair enough you're
going to have to find a farmer yeah yeah
no Fair on purpose but obviously this is
this is just something like I have an
idea of who knows like you probably just
saw like a Tik Tok one day don't bring
that up oh my God no maybe like
obviously maybe things can change I got
to I just I need to and and I say this
like in the nicest way you just don't
seem like a farm chick I get that but
like you don't seem like a chick that
would be super like happy on a farm I
feel like it comes across that but me
personally you might I I don't know who
knows like me personally that's just my
idea of a guy who' be willing to like
you know have a different part of
civilization for us together as a family
okay so um you want to be married by 28
where where do you meet men typically
now um I don't go on dating apps anymore
if you say Instagram no no no I don't
even go I don't I don't I don't do you
know what me personally I used to do
that before but now I just completely
exclude that I just allow it to like
naturally happen okay and do you
approach guys in public no okay so how
would you expect to meet a guy if you're
not doing Instagram dating apps I'm not
really expecting anything like I'm not
really going out my way to really
perceive that anymore okay so how do you
expect to have that outcome if you don't
go out of your way for it I'm not
looking for love right now okay but you
said you wanted to be married by 28 but
I have that's that's I don't know like
me personally I feel like come in a pool
of like I don't really know where people
go to actually look for their
person no seriously I wouldn't I
wouldn't go I wouldn't go online I
wouldn't go online anymore because like
if that person's drawing to me online
then that's fine but like I feel like
I'm still starting again when it comes
to actually like dating especially
because now like I feel like everything
is so online I feel like kind of taking
that away I feel like it's just a
different it's a different type of
finding someone yeah but the the issue
we have right right now is men don't
really approach anymore like I think I
can't remember the surveys they've done
but it's the majority of men aren yeah
well and you know many friends I have
that are just scared to talk to girls
yeah well well it's because like girls
approach them that's why they no no no
no it doesn't happen doesn't happen
either but guys are actually terrified
of women really yeah well there there's
been too many like false accusations
girl freak out like just terrified wow
yeah well I mean women like will you
know call men creepy or like do a
like I just think the men are kind of
tired of this [__] I don't know I've
heard that I've heard guys are just
tired I've heard the women of this
generation they're just B they're just
for the bin that's all that's what I've
heard but I'm like yeah well no and it's
more just to think about like how we get
like women I just think for some reason
we expect certain outcomes but we do
nothing to get it but I'm not going to
lie cuz not saying that like I'm not new
but how do women actually get men like
how do women actually got of the way to
kind of approach men do you know what
I've noticed one thing sorry you know
I've noticed a lot with women like just
a lot of females that I've been around
or whatever I I feel like back to what
you were saying earlier on about the
hierarchy of men I feel like a lot of
women just expect like men to come with
everything like just to come as um you
know providers come with no children
come with uh perfect manners dates this
that money that's what women today are
expecting and and to be like let's be
real not every man's going to have that
you know well it's like are we perfect
yeah we're not we don't have half the
things that we're expecting as women you
know so it's like you like you have to
be realistic when you're searching for
someone and yeah but you're not this is
the problem this is the problem with
women and I agree I I absolutely agree
um and that's probably where a lot of
women are going wrong why they can't
find love because they're looking as you
said they're looking for that like you
know Instagram the guy this you know
taking the girl on dates and going to
all the fancy restaurants and roses and
fast cars and that's what they're
looking you how many guys take do you
know how many guys take a girl to The
Shard on the first date noot mental to
not a lot because they don't that's no
no no a lot a lot wait really a lot oh a
lot like the new generation everyone
goes to The Shard now just on the first
date younger guys
crazy that's what girls are they think
that's the standard that's what girls
are wanting like they're not thinking of
the of of the the normal things like
family values and how he treats you in
the home how we talks life into you how
he's going to raise your kids like girls
are not looking at these things they're
looking at oh red roses yeah fast cars
dats pictures restaurants snaps like
that's what they're looking at well if
you if you wanted to meet guys in the
real world like um the way the way I
think about it is like there's guy
events so like a box like where do men
hang out oh okay like a boxing match you
know but the thing is like I really
think if women want to meet men in the
real world they kind of have to initiate
it CU men just start approaching yeah
wow yeah crazy right they have to say hi
but advice for people that actually want
to meet people for marriage I think a
lot of women don't even know where to
find good men yeah and the reality is
you shouldn't be going out into the
world to go and look for a man that you
want to get married to that's that's the
fastest way to find the wrong type of
guy if you want get married there are so
many places you can look first of all
look in your friend groups look at all
the guys you
friended if you if you don't find
where's your husband in your friend zone
if you don't find any of them attractive
then go to your parents go to your
aunties your cousins ask about their
friends because what you can get is you
can get a guy that will come with like
his full DBS check if you're going out
into the world and just going to speak
to some random guy how do you even know
if he's a serial killer or nothing but
if you're getting recomendations from
people that you trust and know then they
can at least give you women love serial
killers I mean yeah they we love we love
but like this is sounding scary you need
to actually meet people through other
people that you already know that that
way you you minimize obviously you can't
minimize all the risk but you minimize
the risk of actually meeting crazy
people cuz I feel like you can meet some
like it might sound really bad what I'm
going to say I probably sound like a a
damn pre but like like I feel like
there's so much risk of meeting people
online nowadays like you hear so many
stories of meeting people online like I
genuinely wouldn't want to meet the love
of my life and then find out oh he's
killed a couple people he's got a couple
bodies on him like I don't I don't you
wouldn't want to meet someone like that
I feel like online it's it's a lot of
deception that's going on here like it's
a lot well and the and the issue online
is the hypergamy is so out of control
cuz every any guy you go on a date with
like that's the top five 10% of men yeah
and I feel like it's just hamy mhm
that's a big word it's like women date
AC cross and up hierarchies okay so it's
like it's basically like women date a
smaller and smaller percentage in men so
online it's only 5% yeah so you're
dating that like any guy that you match
with you're probably dating a guy that
everybody's dating yeah no it's true
it's very true like yeah yeah it's just
I feel like online it's just it's very
scary now I'd rather just enjoy my life
on I'm single and just wait from them
really what what about you um Mr [__]
boy yeah um what was the question again
what's your plan for your life you want
do you want to get married uh do you
know what with the right person yeah
okay what yeah I want that happy um I
want that happy ending so you're but I
only learned that recently do you know
what I mean and then um I got a bit
heartbroken so that all went out the
window you treated her too good maybe
I'm asking that's what you said earlier
that if you I don't really know cuz I I
don't know what women okay actually
think anymore cuz you l a mad you lot of
menal so when when would you like to be
married um I don't I don't have a date
if it happens it
happens cuz like before I was thinking
like I don't want marriage I don't want
kids I don't want any of that and then
obviously for the right person I think
that will change do you but I don't know
when that person is going to come along
would you prefer marriage or a long-term
relationship um it depends on the person
okay it really depends on the person
okay you'd be open to it depends on if I
la her that
much and what about you you want to stay
married
yeah he had to say that what hang do you
do you guys have kids yeah yeah okay how
many just one just one do you want more
no so my daughter's 12 now so oh no way
there's a bit bit of a gap a gap if we D
another one go for the
second my sister there three seats on a
plane like it's perfect yeah hey my
sister's 10 years younger than
me right yeah well but I'm also one at
10 so wow yeah different different but
who I know I'm I'm Catholic and Irish so
it's just it's what we do
okay um okay well thank you guys for
coming out this was a great show let's
give a little round of applause thank
you I love it I love it when I have
guests that are just very open-minded I
felt like everyone was very open-minded
nobody got like offended or triggered it
was a lot of fun um so why don't we do
uh final thoughts um and you can tell
people where to find you starting here
and then go around okay so my name is
simma um I am an artist and um reality
TV show star is that what they call it
and you can catch me on simma UK on
Instagram and simma UK on Twitter and
simma UK on Tik
Tok um well my name is D _ Chanel on
Instagram um I also have a podcast
called call me before you sleep and um
you can find me on Twitter at
days1 and um Tik Tock um Happy Days
Triple
7 yo my name's fboy Tony on all
platforms just F boy Tony singer rapper
I'm out there I mean come hear me that's
it that's it that's how we shout it out
right mhm cool yeah that's it sweet boy
and you can catch me at uh dos Magic on
Instagram if you want to see some magic
videos I know people were disappointed
they didn't get to see
any um okay thank you guys all for
coming um a couple announcements guys
before we end the show and now I'm going
to read uh your super chats that you
sent um okay so first of all guys we are
looking to sign um talent in the London
office I am going to be going back and
forth a lot between here and the us
we're starting an office
I think we decided actually on La um
today so you know I know that came out
of left field because we didn't think
we're were going to do la but um I know
it wasn't even on the on the options but
I think that's where we're I mean I
don't know guys I've changed my mind 10
times but I think that's what we're
going to do so um we are looking to sign
YouTube Talent here so what does it mean
to be a YouTube Talent basically you're
part of our Network we we do everything
for you um you just show up and talk
depending on what show we would launch
so if you're interested message my
Instagram just pearly things one um give
me your pitch for a show um tell me who
your audience is what you'd want to do
and um give me like some videos If you
talking or something just so I could see
it if we think you maybe be a good fit
we'll come in and have you test it
out um also guys merch women shouldn't
vote if you want to take away these
rights please link is in the description
um it's the audacity network. store
that's the audacity network. store okay
um super chats 93e topai funny how U men
expect a stable women or women funny how
women expect a stable man that provides
but never chooses Indians or Asians um
they are they choose the perfect
Instagram picture for status um magic M
how about um stop bullying the girl in
the blue for her hopes and dreams and
stop belittling her oh that's so cute
thank
you um
did I belittle you I don't think you did
I feel like if anything I think I left
you with an open mind even more so I
like I thought we got along like I
didn't I didn't no but thank you that's
um okay um Pearl you you see the Adam
and Eve judgment the order now see love
as Truth The Ten Commandments truth
comes down and respect goes uh Pearl's
just mad she can't monetize Beauty
because she's as beautiful as an ironing
board back to the kitchen you
um all right an ironing board really
really guys you know but you paid you PA
iron boards come in different colors
honestly if they pay me for it I'll read
it I don't care um okay guys yeah so
YouTube
Talent um I'm trying to think the the
merch do we have any other announcements
King that I need to go through no okay
we got a show tomorrow um same time so
make sure you tune in tomorrow right
after this we're going to be posting the
episode of pearl daily so make sure you
um tune in for that also guys we have
our fourth tier which is a one-on-one
call with me once a month if you want to
know how to get how to get a million
subscribers in a year sign up for that
or just apply to be a YouTube Talent
like the video on your way out subscribe
and I'll talk